안녕하십니까. 재미턴 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬린 모브리프
7월 16일 목요일 1부입니다. 내일
재현절이 법정 공유일이 됐기 때문에
이번 주 주라이브는
오늘이 마지막일 것 같습니다. 1부
시작은 중국 전일시장 왕정부장님과
함께 하겠습니다.
>> 네. 어제 시전은 그렇게 좋지
않고요. 대형 IPO 상장 이슈로
상수 매너스 임정 9%에 빠졌습니다.
반면은 흥선의 지수 플러스 1.3%
오라 하고요. 정시 거대면 2.6조
외양까지 내려갔습니다. 업종별 좀
보시면 부동산 필 소비제 헬스케어
업진 강세였고 밤면은 IT
커뮤니케이션 소재 업진이
약세였습니다.
요월 부동산 지표 나왔고요. 가격
지수는 하락부 계속 축소되고
있습니다. 그리고 일선 도시는 동물
대비는도 우아가고 있고요.이 이 허세
힘 부동차 업주인 컨셉되었습니다.
보리 부동산은 4% 올라가고요. 조상
부동산는 5.4% 만크 A는 2.6%
라왔습니다. 범주도 동반
상승했습니다. 왜냐면 범주는 범사들이
그 부동산 좀 많이 가지고 있잖아요.
그래서 범주로 올라왔어요. 총구
인수는 4% 총구는 2.7% 신화
보원은 1.5% 올라왔어요.
대행po 성장 등 기대함으로 정권주도
강세되었습니다. 종신 정보는 2%
올라가고요. 종신 검토는 3% 도망는
2.7% 올라왔습니다. 종신 증관은
이번 그 CXMT 상장에 조정한
사입니다. 그래서 최근면 주가는 반등
나오고 있습니다. 6월 달 소비 근매
데이터도 나왔습니다. 동기 대비
풀어서 저하는 소식으로 소비자 권용주
강세 보여고요. 그머는 3% 우량의
4%주는 7% 조신의 3%
올라갔어요.
이번기 그 기계 수출 데이터 허조로
기계 관련주도 상승했습니다. 3일
종업는 3% 소금 기계는 2%
나왔어요.
2차 증지 관련주 어제도 반등
나오고요. CT는 2.5% 고향
테크는 5% 나왔습니다. 한편은 흥선
대형 테크주들이 다수선했습니다.
텅슨트 4% 아리바바는 2.4%
돌아왔어요. 반면은 반도체 PCB
CC 광통신 권리주 어세 다
빠졌어요. 신념물 구체 금리 어제
염증p 선성했습니다. 념을 구체
견디는 2.7 PB 선하고 위암화
확률은 그냥 유치했습니다.음
감사합니다. 저희가 하루 시황을 볼
때 보통 이제 매크로 지표 때문에
또는 기업 실적 발표하는 기간에는
기업 실족 때문에 기업의 주가들이 좀
변동성을 보이는데 어 매크로 지표 볼
때 저희가 보통 유가 금리 환율 이제
이런 것들 보니까요. 뭐 예를 들면
유가가 갑자기 뭐 전쟁이나 뭐 이슈
때문에 5% 10% 확 오르면 정의주
주가가 좋고
>> 또 유가 그러니까 석유와 관련되 있는
것이 원가가 되는 업종들은 당연히 안
좋을 거고
>> 금리도 마찬가지로 금리가 오르면
은행처럼 금리가 좀 오르는 구간일 때
좋은 그런 기업들은 어 좀 증식 아
주가가 강세를 보이는데
>> 뭐 그 반대는 또 반대고
>> 환율도 마찬가지고요. 이제 그런데 어
쭉 이제 왕부장님이 오늘은 이런 이런
이유들 때문에 혹은 이런 이런 매크로
지표들 때문에 아니면 그 통계 발표
때문에 어떤 업종이 좋구나 나쁘거나
말씀해 주시면 너무 이해가 잘 돼요.
그런 어떤 로직에다 맞는데 논리에
맞는데
>> 어 큰 틀에서 요즘 이렇게 말씀해
주시는 거를 한 일주일 2주일 단위로
묶어 보면
>> 어 저는 약간 중국도 종목 확산 있는
거 같다는 생각이 좀 들어요.
막 오르던 종목들 어 우리 왕부장이
제가 말씀드렸을 처음 말씀드렸을 때
10조였는데 지금 30조 됐어요. 뭐
이런 기업들
>> 그런 것들이 상대적으로 아 이제
매크로적인 환경이 좀 좋더라도 조금
덜어오르고 낙폭이 컸던 기업들이
반등을 좀 하고 그런 것 같은데
>> 동의해 주십니까? 아니면 어떻습니까?
>> 네.네 맞습니다. 그거는 맞고요.
지금 다 확산된 들어가는 그
느낌이고요. 세터적으로 보면 어제는
상지 매너% 바뀌었지만
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 섹터적으로 보시면
>> 어 IT 섹터는 3.6%에 빠졌어요.
되게 깊게 빠져고요. 그리고
커뮤니케이션은 여기서 보면 1.2%에
빠졌지만 개별 조치 보면은 거의 5%
6% 정도 빠졌어요.
뭐 대형주 뭐
국경제 권영주 뭐 부동산 쪽으로 또
거의 7% 8% 오라는 장세가 딱 그
확산되는 느낌이 있고요. 약간 미국
시도 비슷한 느낌이 나오고 있습니다.
>> 네. AI발 증시 주도에 대해서는
뭐게 바뀌었나 그런 것에 대해서 아마
바뀌었다고 생각하시는 분 별로 없을
것 같은데
>> 맞습니다.
>> 너무 주도주가 이제 쏠리다 보니까
지나치게 낙폭이 컸던 업종이나
종목들로 어 다시 좀 그쪽에 상대적
온기가 좀 갔다가 그다음에 또 어떻게
될지 좀 보는 그런 구간이 아닌가
하는 생각을 좀 해 봤습니다.
>> 네.
장님 말씀해 주실 때 밑에 준비해
주신 종목 보니까 며칠 전에이 왜
이렇게 많이 빠졌어요라고 위에 그
말씀 하면서 좀 언급해 주셨던 중국
면세입니다.
>> 네. 중후 연세 실적 나왔어요. 지문
시가 종은 거의 23조만까지
내려왔습니다. 옛날에 홀사는 아마
80조까지 추가 좀 찍고 내려왔어요.
포드 피안는 지금 19배 정도
됐고요. 옛날에 거의 피는
최성단까지는 80배 정도 받았어요.
충분 면세 시장 MS는 1.6이고요.
72.3% 차지하고 있고 하 연세
시장에서 90% 정도 차지하고
있습니다. 어 3번기 매출에는
동일대비 2% 감소하고 순위 있는
동일 대비 19.5% 5%
증가했습니다. 역산호 화면은 2분기
매출하는 동일 대비 -3% 감소 수익
있는 동의 15% 증가했어요. 다만
시정 예선치 대비는 하회였습니다.
기저 허리 면세 사업 부형 증 실시에
등용인 선반기 실조는 개선 주세가
지소되고 있고요. 다만 요가 급등에
따라서 연한 수요는 2분기 좀
축소되었어요.
어 2분기 실전 회보세가 1분기
대비는 소포 전되었습니다. 4월부터
5월까지 명세 데이터 다르면 매출에는
동의 정도 증가했어요. 1분기는 그냥
142억 외형으로 동의가는
변되나 되었어요. 다만요 일부
회보되었는데 당호자 영효 기간은 명세
매출는여 외로 잡았어요. 그래서
동의대비 8.6% 전달했습니다.
그래서 뭐 요런데 좀 나쁘지 않다고
생각할 수 있어요. 수위선으로도
개선되고 있습니다. 3번기 GP
마진는 동의.73% 73% 화대하고
이기p 마지는 동일 대비 1.44%
화대했습니다. 어 조합 있는 할인율
축석 그리고 외화 강사에 따른 매입가
하락이 두 가지 요인 때문에 마진으로
개선되었습니다. 어 군인청 리포트
보면은 하반기에 요한 수요 회복
전망고 매수 위원을 일지했습니다.
연 여름 방하 시점 진입 그리고 요가
하라 따라서 요한 수요는 다시 증가
이상이고요. 한방기 외공인 입보자수는
동의대 20% 증가했습니다. 왜냐면
충구 지금 그 무입 오비자 입구 정체
계속 화대하고 있어요.
>> 아 그 국가별로
>> 맞아요. 국가별로 그래서 다 비자
없이 돌아갈 수 있습니다. 그래서
외국인이 보좌수는 동일 대비 20%
정도 증가하고 있고 회사 비용 관련
한해율 축소에 따라서 마진으로 계산
가능성이 있습니다. 다만은 2번기
실조 하회 당는 요인으로 원래 내년
내년 수 있는 가가지 대비는 4%
5% 8 7% 하용 조전했어요. 어이
정관사는 어 목표주다 제시하지
않았어요. 그래서 제가 마음속에는
그냥이 피어는 종이 있어요.이 피어
피어 잡으면은 15배부터 30배 정도
받을 수 있어요.
>> 그래서 TP는 대중 37보다 50
정도 됩니다. 어제 종가 대비는
대초는 32% 다운세 그리고 37%
업세 있습니다.
>> 음. 감사합니다.
>> 어 수요일 전에 중국 면세 잠깐 위에
표 보면서 말씀 나을 때
>> 네
>> 어 중국인들이 이제 내수 어 국내관
많이 할수록이 회사 실적이 좋아질
가능성이 높다.
>> 네
>> 그렇게 말씀 주셨고 얘기했었어요.
>> 네. 어, 그리고 다시 얘기하면 어,
중국인들이 많이 여행을 다니는게 일단
중요한데 해외보다는 국내 여행을 많이
다니는게 더 중요하고
>> 맞습니다.
>> 그리고 여행을 많이 다니려면 휴일이
좀 많은 것도 도움이 많이 될 텐데
>> 맞습니다.
>> 급 생각났는데 중국은 한국보다 효율이
많습니까? 적습니다.
>> 아, 그거는
>> 좀 따져 봐야 돼요.
>> 아, 네. 따져봐야 왜냐면 충구는 그
효율은 많지만 어,
그 아니면 충구 효율은 항상 영효가
많아요.
>> 음. 그 기 기 영효 맞아요. 그런
거는 많고요. 왜냐면
>> 어 대충 그 촌절 영효 때는도 거의
2주 정도 쉬는 날 쉬 쉬는 기간도
있고 고절도 거의 7일 정도 쉬는
구간이에요. 그래서 대충 이거 긴영
효가게 많고요.
>> 그 뭐 하루 이틀는 휴율을 그렇게
많이 쓰는다고 어네 그러겠습니다.네
알겠습니다. 율이 좀 많아지고 또 어
근무 시간 이런 것들이 좀 줄어들수록
여행소는 구조적으로 좀 어 높아질
텐데 아직 그런 것까지는 아니다
하더라도 그리고 여기 써 주신 것처럼
>> 내국인이 어 국내 여행을 많이 하는
것도 중요한데 외국인 입국이 많이
되는 것도 도움이 되겠습니다.음네
>> 맞습니다.네
외국인은 들어오면은 거기서 가서
쇼핑하면은 군잡고요. 그래서 이거는
뭐음
되게 어 저 뭐 지금은이이 실적
모멘텀으로 잡으면은 그 외국이에요.
전에는 다 충분 내부적으로 소소가
되면은 그 1분제 처분제 그 투자
포인트이고 근데 외국인 2부자수는
20% 증가해도 이거는 되게 애매한
상황이고요. 외국이 이고자
주로 그 가는 건 아니고요. 음
>> 우리 그 군내는 우리 그 수월 가서는
뭐 러대 면세 이런 거 갈 수
있잖아요. 여기서는 약간 세조도로
생각하시면 됐고요. 승리
>> 하이난을 가야 되는구나.
>> 네. 봐세요. 하는 가면은 이건 쇼핑
뭐 소비 금면 울 수 있고 그런데
대중 외고 있는 그쪽으로는 가지 않고
내륙 시전을 많이 가고요. 상하의
메이징적으로
>> 아
>> 그래서이 호사는 실제로 양권을 그렇게
>> 네
>> 여기 마지막 줄에 그 멀티플의 밴드를
좀 이렇게 넓게 잡으신 이유는네
>> 어 왜냐면이 회사가 옛날에 되게
옛날에 되게 거핑가 받았어요. 과거
평균적으로 하단하면은 거의 30배
20회보다 30배 정도 받을 수
있어요. 지금 호텔시나 보면은 또
거의 14배 13배밖에 없어요.
그래서이 비사게 받은 이유가 없어요.
왜냐면 MP 마진 5% 바에 없어요,
지금.
>> 네. 그래서 높게 받던 이유가 없다고
생각하고 있고 다만 중구 정책은이
멀티브 좀 비상형 있고요. 그래서
대충는 뭐 20일 정도가 받을 수요
다만 20일 적용해도
>> 없애도 없어요.
>> 별로 없죠.
>> 네.
이게 특정 국가의 이제 국가와
관련되어 있는 이제 멀티플 멀티플
할증과 할인 요소가 있기 때문에
>> 어 해외에 있는 기업들과 동일하게
비교하기는 좀 어려운데 최근에 그게
이제 하이닉스하고도
>> 하이닉스 ADR과 본주와 이제
궤리디도 그런 차원으로 이해할 수
있을 것 같은데 중국 시장이 멀티플이
좀 높다 이런 말씀 주셨고 반면에
이제이 기업이 과거에 받았던 멀티플
밴드보다는 계속 우아향하고 있기
때문에 비즈니스 모델이 이 어
아니다. 더 이상은 나빠질게 없다라는
>> 단초를 제공해 주기 전까지는 조금 더
보수적으로 보는게 맞지 않을까?
>> 네.
>> 오늘은 그래서 검토 정도.
>> 아유, 맞습니다. 네. [웃음]
>> 알겠습니다. 위에 표도 있으니까
계속해서 좀 여쭤보고 공부하도록
하겠습니다.
>> 중국 시장 여기까지 보고 미국으로
넘어가 보겠습니다. 전일 미국 시장
창민% 부탁드립니다.
>> 네. 전일 미국 시장
말씀드리겠습니다. 전일 미국 정신은
PPI가 예상치를 하여 물과 안정이
제악인된 가운데 단도체 업종이 2%
높게 불락했음에도 대형 기술주로의
순환매 힘입어 상승 마감했습니다.
오늘은 중국 청신 메모리의 성장
청의하기 족발한 반도체 하락이랑 금리
부담이 낮아지며 성장주 전반으로 먼지
순환매 그리고 하루 만에 9% 급락
보이며 괴리율을 좁히기 시작한 SK
하이닉스 ADR까지 정리해 드릴
예정입니다.
먼저 미국 주요 지수 보겠습니다.
SMP 500은 0.38% 38%
오는 7,572포인트로 마감하며 이틀
연속 상승했습니다. 그리고 나스닥은
0.62% 다운은 0.29%
올랐고요. 러셀 이천도 0.39%
% 상승했습니다. 반면 어제 2.5%
반등했던 필라델피아 반도체회가 하루
만에 2.08% 하락하며 다시 방향을
아래로 뚫었습니다.
그래서 우측 SP 500의 업종별
보시면 커뮤니케이션이 2.8%
급등하며 지수 상승을 홀로
견인하다시피 했고요. 자유소비제도
1.4% 올라주는 모습 보였습니다.
반면 반도체 전반의 약세로 점기 정보
기술이 0.1% 1% 하락했고
유틸리티도 1% 하락했습니다.
>> 음.
>> 물가 지표가 좋았는데도 업종관
온도차가 나타난 것은 반도체 주식의
자금이 좀 대형 성장주로 이동한
영향으로 보입니다. 다음으로 금리와
유가 보시겠습니다. 미국체 10년물
금리는 3b넬인 4.56%로 이틀
연속 하락했고요. 6월 생산자 물가
지수가 에너지 가격 하락을 반영해서
전월 대비 0.3% 하락하고 전망치를
하여했습니다. 그 5월 수치도
1.1% 상승해서 0.6 6%로 크게
하향 조정됐고요. 전일 CPI에
의해서 PPI까지 안정이 좀 확인되자
7월 분리 인상 확률이 CME
패드워치 기준 10.2%까지
낮아졌습니다.
여기에 6연은 윌리엄스 총재가 물가가
이미 정점을 지났으며 현재 금리
수준이 물가를 2%로 되돌리기에
적절하다고 평가한 점도 힘을 보는
것으로 보입니다. 그 WTI는 미국의
일한 추가 공습과 해상 봉쇄 재개
소식의 1.3% 오른 8.3달러를
3달러를 기록했지만 양측 모두 외교적
해결을 언급하고 있어서 좀 상승폭은
제한되는 모습 보였습니다.
다음으로 중간에 위치한 52주 신고가
19였습니다. 어제도 뱅크 오브
아메리카 모건 스텔릭 골드만스 JP
모건 등 금융주가 명단을 이어갔고요.
기술주에서는 포티네과 크로드
스트라이크 그리고 4% 급등한 애플이
사성 최고가로 이름을 올렸습니다.
반도체가 빠진 자리를 금융과
소프트웨어 그리고 대용 기술주가 치운
모습입니다.
그리고 다음으로 좌측 비테크 및 주요
종목 보시겠습니다. 어제장의 핵심은
반도체에서 대형 기술주로의
순환매였습니다. 애플이 4% 알파벳이
3.2% 메타가 3.1% 아마존이
3% 그리고 마이크로소프트가 2.8%
가량 오르며 대형 기술주가 일제히
강세를 보였습니다. 각자 지료도 좀
있었는데요. 애플은 AI 반독체
스타트업 인수를 검토 중이라는 보도가
있었고 중국 규제 당국이 알리바 Q1
모델 기반의 애플 인텔리전스 출시를
승인했다는 소식이 겹쳤습니다. 그리고
알파벳은 워렌 버핏이 버크쇼의 알파벳
투자를 직접 주도했다고 밝힌 점이
재료였습니다.
다만 개별 재료 이상으로 주목해야 할
부분은이 자금 이동의 방향인데요. 그
물가 안정으로 금리 부담이 낮아지는
국면에서 회가 실적이 좋게 찍기는
종목이 국한대기보다 할인율에 민감한
성장주 전반의 밸루에이션을 확산되는
모습이 나타났습니다. 물가 안정으로
금리 부담이 낮아진 환경이 이런
성장주 선에 우호적인 배경이 됐다는
점을 함께 주목해 주시면 되겠습니다.
다음으로 아예 반도체 아래쪽 반대
반도체 쪽 보시겠습니다. 마이크론이
8% 샌디스크가 8.1%
그리고 웨스턴 디지털 8.8% 8%
급락하는 모습 보였고요. 인텔과
AMD도 3% 4%대 하락
보였습니다. 그리고 급락을 축발한
핵심 원인으로 그 중국 메모리 업체의
증설 우려가 있었는데요. 그 글로벌
4위 디램 업체인 중국 창신 메모리가
목요일 중국 증시 상장을 위해서
85억 달러 규모의 측력에 돌입한다는
소식에 그 법용 디램 시장에서 중국의
공급이 좀 늘어날 수 있다는 경제감이
부각된 것으로 보입니다. 다만이는
AI 메모리 수요 자체가 꺾였다기보다
앞으로의 경쟁 구도에 대한 우려가
밸루에이션이 높아진 종목들의 차익
실현을 좀 자극했다로 저는
생각했습니다. 그럼 ASML은 실적
호주와 가이던스 상형 그리고
2027년까지의 이유주 급증 언급에
2.2% 상승하는 모습 보였습니다.
그리고 어제 말씀드렸던 SK 하이닉스
ADR 베리얼 문제도 한번 짚어
드리고 보자 하는데요. 좀 하루 만에
방향이 잡힌 모습입니다. ADR은
9% 하락하며 전일 27% 급등분의
좀 대량을 다수를 되돌렸는데 전일
급등을 만들었던 옵션 거에서 프리미엄
축소를 견영은 풋옵션이 좀
유입됐고요. 그리고 레버리지 ETF
운영사들이 목표 배수를 맞추는
과정에서 메모리 좀 출해된 것으로
보입니다. 더 중요한 것은 구조적인
변화인데 예탁 결제원이 오는
29일부터 본주와 ADR간 상호
전환을 허용하기 때문에 그 50%까지
벌어졌던 프리미엄이 찰거래를 통해
빠르게 해소될 가능성이 높습니다.
다만 좀 주의하셔야 될 부분은 그
본주를 ADR로 전환하는 거는 사전에
신청을 하고 물량에도 제한이 있다는
점을 고려하셔야 될 것 같습니다.
다음으로 금융 쪽도 짧게 짚고
넘어가겠습니다. 블랙록이 6.6%
급등하면 1년 만 1년 여만에 가장
큰 폭을 올랐습니다. 운용 자산이
15.3조 달러로 사상 최대를
기록했고 군기 순 유 유의백액이
1917억 달러. 그리고 상반기
누적으로는 역대 최대임 3,210억
달러가 들어왔습니다. 액티브 전략에
530억 달러가 유입되고 성가 보수가
전년에 세 배를 넘어서는 등 고마진
사업으로의 무게 이동이 이번 실적으로
확인된 점이 강세의 배경입니다.
모건스텔리도 주식 트레이딩 매출이
63억 달러로 예상치 45억 달러를
좀 크게 오돌랐고 하상 최대 실적을
냈지만 전일 골드만 싹스 실적이 좀
선반영됐다는 평가가 있어서 0.4%
>> [콧방귀]
>> % 상승에 거친 모습입니다. 그리고
우측에 그 자동차 선업 쪽 보시면
루시드가 28.8%로 좀 크게
상승하는 모습 보였는데요. 기존에 좀
파선 우려에 대해서 노이즈가 있었는데
루시드 측에서 그 공식적으로 그 전면
반박하는 보도를 내면서 28.8%
8% 상승 크로 좀 급락한 부분을
크게 반등으로 되돌리는 모습 보여주고
있었습니다. 그래서 오늘 내용 좀
정리해서 말씀드리자면
어제 시장은 CPI에이어서 PPI까지
좀 물가 안정이 확인되었고 지수는
올랐지만 그 중국 창신 메모리의 상장
청력으로 메모리 공급 확대가 좀
무려가 부각됐고요. 그리고 메모리
종목에 대한 경계심 자극했고 금리
부담이 낮아지는 공면에서 자금이 대형
성장주를 좀 옮겨간 하루였습니다.
금리 분함이 낮아지는 국면에서 시장의
수혜가 실적주를 좀 넘어서 성장주
전반으로 확산되는 흐름을 좀 계속
지켜봐야 되지 않나라고 저는
생각하고요. 그리고 SK 하이닉스
ADR이 29일 상호전환 개시라도
개율 해소가 좀 시작된만큼
본주와 ADR의 수급 변화를 함께 좀
계속해서 주시해 볼 필요가
있겠습니다. 네. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 어, 첫 페이지에 표를
쭉 보니까 금리, 환율, 그리고 유가
요런 것들은 이제 방향이 좀 엇갈리긴
했지만 어, 고점에서 주식 시장에게
좀 부담을 주었던 레벨들은 조금씩
완화되는 거 같다. 그런 느낌을
받았고 왼쪽에 저는 그 빅테크 및
주어 종목이라고 해서 애플부터 맨
밑에 브로드컴까지 보여 주신이 표를
보고 오늘 좀 와라고 생각했던 부분이
어 한
달 남진 내외인 거 같은데요. 제가
아침 방송을 그 진행했던 그 구간에
언젠가 봤을 때 SMP 500
기준으로 여기에 빅테크 및 주요
종목들이 어 SMP 500보다 아웃
퍼포을 했던 종목이 한두 개밖에
없었던 걸로 기억합니다. 그런데 지금
보니까 이미 애플은 20%나 넘게
올라서 SP 500 연초 이후에 지금
10.6% 6% 상승 중인데 그보다
뭐 두 배 가까이지 몰랐고 구글도
그렇고 아마존 비슷하고 그리고
엔비디아나 브로드컴도 이제
아웃퍼폼포머를 좀 돌아서서 어 대형
빅테크들로 이제 자금이 좀 올리면서
이쪽에 집중적으로 투자했던 펀드들도
상대 성과 관점에서는 이제 어 나쁘진
않겠구나라는 생각을 좀 했습니다.
다만 이제 연초 이후에 어 너무 많이
그 아웃퍼폼을 했던 메모리 직접적으로
메모리 관련한 종목들 그리고 데이터
센터와 관련된 그 주변에 있는
종목들이 뭐 연초에 막 두 배 세 배
이상 올랐다가 지금 그것을 좀
반납하고 있는 그런 국면이구나라는
생각을 컨트에서 해 봤습니다. 전
말씀주신 블랙락도 사실 주가 등락률이
뭐 5% 10% 이렇게 되는 기업이
아닌데 7% 가까이 오른 거 보면 한
번에이 얌전했던 종목이 주가의 실적을
반영하는 것이 아닌가 하는 생각 좀
해 봤습니다. 감사합니다. 2부에서
어 초보사장과 함께 미국 시장을 좀
더 자세히 알아보도록 하겠습니다.
가상자산으로 [콧방귀]
넘어가겠습니다. 준역조임님.네 네.
가상자 시장 말씀드리겠습니다. 어,
차트부터 보시면 되는데요. 어, 가격
흐름 굉장히 나쁘지 않았습니다. 제가
65,000불을
넘어서 한 65,400불이 정도를
거래가 되 거래가 된다라고 하면 좀
추세가 바뀔 수 있는 그런
구간이다라고 말씀 한번 드린 적이
있었는데요. 어제 그 구간에 맞고
저항을 맞고 내려오긴 했습니다. 한
65, 지금 6만 6 4,800불
정도의 거래가 되고 있는데요. 어쨌든
그 부분을 이제 정말 터치를 하고
내려왔다는 점은 굉장히 공적이다라고
볼 수가 있을 것 같고 어제 CPI요
PPI도 굉장히 잘 나왔다 보니까
그런 부분들이 위험 자산 시장 선호에
조금 더 기여를 받지 않았나 이렇게
생각이 들고 제 그냥 개인적인 생각일
수도 있는데요. 그냥 반도체 쪽에서
어제 그 수급상으로 어 뭔가 쏠림이
있다가 그런 것들 좀 완화되는 흐름이
나올 수도 있나 나오는 거 같아. 그
예를 들어서 어 다른 쪽 섹터로 어
수급이 이동한다라고 하면 어
비트코인도 그 비트코인이나 가장자산
시장도 어 그런 수에 받는 섹터 중
하나가 아닐까 그니까 다른 수납매가
도한 섹터가 아닐까 생각을 어
말씀드렸는데 그런 부분이 비슷하게
이어질 수도 있는 거 아닌가 하는
생각하고 있습니다. 예를 들어서 어
반도체 시장이 어 반도체 미국에서
반도체가 빠지고 있을 때 비트코인이
같이 원래 빠지는 그런 시장이 안
좋으면 같이 빠지는 모습을
보여줬었는데 지금은 그런 부분이
아니라 오늘 경고하게 버티거나 오히려
반대로 상승하는 모습을 보여주고
있다.이 정도 흐름으로 말씀드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 제가 방금
말씀드린 것처럼 비트코인의 저항 구간
어제 어 65,000불 이상을
상의하게 되면서 어 거기 지금 그
제가 그어 놓은 선에다가 그걸
올라갔다가 다시 저항을 맞고
내려왔다이 정도로 보시면 될 거 같고
여기 강하게 돌파한다라고 하면 그
채널 밑에 채널에 있는 위에 채널에서
놀게 되니까 어 그런 부분은 이제
7만 불대를 바라볼 수 있게 된다
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
비트코인 피레드 인덱스 보시면 아직
공포 구간에 있고요. 25 정도를
기록하고 있고 이게 타이밍상으로 제가
시기월이 정확히 맞는지 안 맞는지
모르겠지만 트러버 대통령이 언급을
하고 나서 항상 그 ETF 순
순유출를 보면 항상 유입세였던 거
같습니다. 이거 트럼프 대통령의
발언을 듣고 ETF가 유입이 되는
건지 아니면 트럼프가 유입이 많이
된다라는 것을 어 알고 있는지 정확히
모르겠지만 아무래도 전자가 좀
가깝다. 전자에 좀 가깝다라고 생각을
하고 있고 어 181밀리언 정도가
유입이 됐다 보니까 어 유입에서
완전히 꺾여서 유출세로 돌아선게
아니다라는 것을 좀 반항 반항적으로
잠깐 보여 준게 아닌가 생각이 들고
어쨌든 유입세가 7월 14일 기준으로
들어왔다 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 주요시 쭉 내려와서 보시면
어 제가 이게 텔레그램이나 뭐 X
같은 데서 어 여러 가지 자료들을
한번 보다가 재밌는게 하나 있어서
가져왔습니다. 예측 시장을 제가
지난번 소개시켜 드린 적이 있고 예측
시장이 굉장히 많이 커지고 있으면서
어 월드컵이나 뭐 어 정치 같은 그런
이벤트들이 있을 때 굉장히 많이
성장한다 이렇게 말씀을 드렸었는데요.
어 SSRN에서 올라온 SSRN이라고
하는 플랫폼이 있더라고요. SSRN는
프리프린트 서버라고 합니다. 그래서
아직 정식 학술지가 아니고 그냥
출판을 했는데 논문들이 약간 공개되는
그런 저장소의 플랫폼이다라고 합니다.
그래서 경제 금융 법학 분야에서는
정식으로 전에 올리기 전에 SSRN에
먼저 올리는 경우가 있어서 좀 빠르고
트렌디한 아이디어를 확인할 수
있다라고 하는데요. 그래서 거기
올라온 어 스탠포드 대학교 그리고
신카포르에 있는 대학교 어 있는
연구원들이 나온 예측 시장의 정산
조작에 대해서 어 발표를 해
줬습니다. 2월 30일 날 발표된
논문이고요. 예측 시장에 상장된
종목들로 인해서 어 현물 시장이
어떻게 조작되는지를 다루고 있습니다.
그래서 비트코인이 5분 동안 5분
뒤에 가격이 어떻게 될지 배팅을 하는
그런 상품들이 있는데 이거를 중심으로
어 현물 시장이 그니까 예측 시장에
있는 상품 때문에 현물 시장이 어떻게
조작되는지를 어 관찰한 결과를 말해
주고 말해 말해 줬다 이렇게 보시면
될 거 같고요. 결론부터 말씀을
드리면 어 예측 시장에서 자산 가격에
연동된 초단기 계약을 만들게 된다라고
하면 계약 보유자가 정산 직전에 현물
시장을 밀어서 가격을 조작하고 그
이익은 주로 리텔 투자자로부터 뺏어는
그 결과를 관찰을 했다라고 합니다.
그래서 자기들이 관찰한 기간 동안에
약 24만 번 정도가 거래가 됐었는데
어 이익을 본 주소 그 가상자산
주소는 820개 정도밖에 안 됐다라고
하거든요. 그래서 그 주소들은 어
대부분 조작일 것이다라고 인식을 하고
있다라고 합니다. 어 조작은
NTM이라고 다 하는 단어를
썼더라고요. near the머니라고
해서 저희 옵션 어에 가까운 그래서
진짜 실제 적중 확률이 높은 거를
NTM이다라고 보시면 될 거 같은데
어 NTM에서 주로 조작이 발생을
하고 시장이 확실하던 결과도 조작을
조작을 한다고 했을 때 적지하는
결과를 뒤집힌다라고 합니다. 그래서
거의 확실시됐던 결과도 예를 들어
조작이 이루어진다라고 하면 34.2%
지금 2%의 확률로 그 결과가
뒤집혔었다라고 말을 하고 있고요.
우려와 다르게 그리고이 계약이 문제를
해결하는 방법은 계약 만기 자체를
늘리면 된다라고 합니다. 어 그럼
조작이 현재 줄어든다라고 하는데요.
15분 계약에서는 5분 계약에서선
조작이 많이 일어날 수 있지만 15분
계약이 된다라고 하면 그 조작이 크게
약화가 된다라고 합니다. 그래서 이게
델타값이 어 15분 계약에서
0.068 정도가 어 로우값으로
된다라고 하고 그리고 어 5분
계약에서는 이게 0.406 406
정도까지 올라간다라고 하니까 5분
계약에서 확실히 어 그 자산 가격에
대한 델타가 많이 올라간다라는 것을
확인할 수가 있을 것 같습니다. 어이
논문이 굉장히 긴 논문이 제가 막 다
읽어 본 건 아니고 중요한 부분이나
중요한 차트 이런 것들 위주로 많이
봤는데 어 그래도 중요한 어 앞에 그
앱스트랙에서
중요할 만한 어 문장이 있는 거
같아서 가져왔습니다. 여기서 뭐라고
하냐면 유동성이 많아졌지만 오히려
가격 발견은 훼손되는 상황이 연출이
된다라고 말을 했습니다. 그래서
실제로 5분 계약이 그 나오고
나서부터 거래량이 굉장히 많이 나오고
마감 직전에 거래량이 많이 나오는
상황들이 관찰이 됐었는데 오히려 이런
것들이 가격을 정확하게 우리가
예측하거나 우리가 저희가 폴리마켓을
보고 결과를 어느덧 힌트를 얻는 그런
상황들을 저희가 많이 봤었잖아요. 어
그런 가격을 발견하데 있어서 오히려
훼손되는 상황이 연출이 됐다라고
합니다. 그래서 이게 가격이 왜 가격
발견이 왜 훼손이 되는지는 제 밑에
차트를 보면서 그 차트나 자료들을
보면서 어 좀 더 자세하게 설명을
드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다. 그래서
왼쪽에 있는 흐름 그 가격 그
차트부터 보시면 주문 흐름이라고 제가
써 놓은 부분이 있는데요. 이게 5분
계약이다 보니까 이걸 초단위로 나눠
준 겁니다. 그래서 3300초까지
나와 있다 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같은데 보시면 300초에 근접했을 때
갑자기 주문 흐름이 막 나오는 것을
확인하실 수가 있습니다. 근데 옵션
같은 것도 그렇고 저희가 옵션 만기
변동성이 굉장히 커지는 것을 주식
시장에서도 관찰을 하는데 어 그러면
어 그냥 옵션 같이 그냥 마감 직전에
주식 그 변동성이 많아지는 거 아니냐
주문이 많아지는 거 아니냐 이렇게
의심을 할 수가 있을 것 같은데요.
바로 오른쪽에 있는 걸 보면 조금
다른 아이디어를 저희가 받쳐실 수
있을 것 같습니다. 리버서 슬롭이라고
하는 추세 전환을 저희가 확인할 수
있는 그런 어 표라고 하는데요.
통계적으로 제가 정확하게 잘은
모르지만 어쨌든 제가 이해한 바로는
여기 레그 여기 렉 가장 밑에 있는
x축에 1에 간접할수록 정산
직전이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
어 정산 직전에 그럼 예를 들어서
여기 정산 직전이고 y축은 평균에
있는 가격이다 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같은데요. 어 주로 가격들 지금이
바들을 보시면 어 주로 평균 때 0
정도의 수렴이 있는 것을 확인하실
수가 있을 것 같습니다. 근데 정산
직전에 보시면 어 이게 1 어 그
-0.1 1 정도까지 갑자기 급격하게
어 그 기울기가 확 줄어드는 것을
보실 수가 있을 것 같은데요. 그럼
예를 들어서 추세가 전환됐다라고 하면
계속 그 마이너스 음수에 있는 추세로
어 계속해서 가야 되 가야지 맞다라고
저기가 볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그러니까 추세가 전환됐으니까 주소가
전환된 채로 계속해서 흐름이 이어져야
되는데 여기 있는 지금 차트를 보시면
그 흐름이 정산 직전에 이어졌다가
다시 한번 회기 다시 한번 평균으로
돌아오는 모습을 보여줍니다. 그래서
예측 시장에서 주문이 나왔던게 조작이
좀 가까운게 아닌가 하는 그런
아이디어를 제시해 주고 있는 어 그런
자료들이다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
밑으로 내려와서 보시면 제가 바이낸스
현물 시장 움직임 그리고 폴리마켓
계약 움직임 이렇게 제목을 지워 놓은
두 개를 보시면 아까 말씀드린 것처럼
니얼더 마켓 ntm 그니까 계약이 어
접전인 것들 접 그러니까 실제 이게
될 확률들이 어 접전인 것들이 어
조금 더 변동성에 크게 나오고 있는
모습을 왼쪽에서 확인하실 수가 있을
것 같습니다. 그래서 가장 왼쪽에
있는 거부터 어 그 순량이고 그
가운데 있는 거는 그 리턴 그니까
수익률이고 가장 오른쪽에 있는게
호가창이다. 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같은데요.이 NTM이 검정색
선이고요. 검정색선이 변동성이 더
굉장히 크고 마감 직전에 급격하게 어
현물 시장에서 거래량이 확 터진다.
이렇게 거래 주문량이 확 나온다.
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고 오른쪽에
있는 폴리마켓은 폴리마켓은 결국에
이제 어 시장을 유동성을 공급하는
공급자들입니다. 어 그래서 가장
오른쪽에 있는 걸 좀 보시면 될 거
같은데요. 가장 오른쪽에 있는 호가창
쪽을 폴리마켓에서 호가창 쪽을 보게
되시면 어 리얼더 마켓 좀 계약이
접전인 것에서 보시면 가장 어
300초 쪽 그러니까 3 그 5분의
급 5분의 접근을 하면 할수록
호가창의 깊이가 점점점 줄어듭니다.
이게 무슨 말이냐고 지금 여기서이
논문에서 설명을 해 주고 있냐면 어이
5분에 가까워질수록이
위험이 계약 자체가 위험하다라는 것을
조작될 위험이 있다라는 것을 어 어느
정도인지를 하고 있기 때문에 마켓
메이커들 시장에서 유동성을 공급하는
사람들이 오히려 호가창의 어 깊이를
좀 줄인다라고 합니다. 왜냐면 이게
조작이 되길 확률이 굉장히 크기
때문에 오히려 거래가 안 되는 거
자체가 어 위험을 조금 감소하는데 좀
도움이 된다라고 하거든요. 그래서
이런 여러 가지 자료들을 봤을 때 어
갑자기 5분 5분에 근접했을 때
갑자기 계약이 늘어나는 거. 그리고
폴리마켓에서 시장을 시장 유동성을
공급하는 공급자들이 어 5분 직전에는
유동성을 좀 줄인다는 거 이런
부분들로 어 의심을 하고 있다라고
합니다. 그래서 실제 결과 그 조작
결과가 어떻게 되는지를 저희가 한번
파악을 해 보면 될 거 같은데 어
실제 조작 결과가 좀 극적인 결과를
나왔다 제가 제목을 지어 놨고요. 어
가장 빨간색 쳐 놓은 부분부터 보시면
될 거 같습니다. 여기 가장 왼쪽에
있는 부분이 9 0.91.0 이렇게
써 있는데 이게이 계약이 될 확률이
그니까 계약이 정확하게 어 성세될
확률이 90% 100% 되는 확률이다
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고요. 세임
디렉션 5% 디렉션 이렇게 써 있는데
같은 방향으로 예를 들어 상 비트코인
상승하고 있었으면 그 방향으로 밀었을
때 어 성공하는 확률 윈트는 97%
가까이 됩니다. 그 더 신기했던 점은
오퍼트 렉션이 더 신기했는데요. 어,
이게 거의 90% 100% 성공할
확률이 높은 계약임에도 불구하고 예를
들어서 조작이 이루어진다라고 하면
34.2%의 %의 확률로 반대
방향으로 계약이 성사가 된다라고
합니다. 그래서 이런 부분들이 가장
오른쪽에 있는 부분 보시면 원래도
90% 100% 있는 구간은 어 성공
확률이 99% 정도가 되는데
반대방향으로 확 갈 확률이 1%
정도밖에 안 되는데 조작으로 인해서
이게 거의 34%까지 올라오는 결과를
봤었다 이런 식으로 설명을 해 주고
있는 것으로 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
바로 오른쪽에 있는 것은 조작의
피해는 주로 리테일 투자들이 봤다라고
합니다. 그래서 실제 조작자들은 한
8.2밀리언 2m년 정도를 이런
계약들에서 어 가져다갔고 어 그
리테일 투자들은이이 똑같은 구간에 한
7.6m년 6년 정도를 잃었다라고
하니까 거의 리테일 투자들에서 어 그
조작자들이 돈을 뺏어 온 거다라고
흐름을 보시면 될 거 같고요. 그럼
이제 옵션을 이제 이게 옵션 옵션
계약 같은 거기 때문에 옵션 계약을
하는 시장 유동성 주 시장 유동성을
제공하는 사람들 입장에서는 어 해징을
하게 됩니다. 그럼 예를 들어서 내가
어 올라가는 계약에 대해서 판다라고
하면 이게 쇼 포지션과 가까이 되기
때문에 옵션을 매도, 콜 옵션을
매도한 거 같이 되기 때문에 현물
비트코인을 조금 사 줘야 됩니다.
그래야 이제 델타증이 되는데요. 저도
그렇게 옵션을 설명을 드려야 될 거
같은데 어 왼쪽에 여기 a B C D
나와 있는데 A가 그 조작이고 어
B가 마켓메이커이고 C가 리테일
투자들이고 D가 바이낸스 현물
움직임입니다. 어 A 쪽 보시면
조작자들은 계속해서 그 콜옵션
콜옵션을 계속해서 하고 있다라고
설명드리는게 좀 편할 것 같은데
올라간다에 상승한 배팅하는 계약들을
계속해서 꾸준히 사고 있는 거로 보실
수가 있을 것 같습니다. 그리고
반대로 마켓메이그 시장 유동성을
제공해 준 사람들은 계속해서 어 그
옵션을 매도하고 있다. 콜 옵션.
그러니까 상승 배팅하는 옵션들을
팔아주고 있다라고 보시면 될 거
같은데요. 그럼 예를 들어서 내가 그
옵션을 매도하는 어 시장 조성자들이
어 델타 해칭을 한다라고 한다라고
하면 현물 매수를 꾸준히 그 포지션을
쌓아야 된다라고 합니다. 근데 뒤로
보시면 어 현물 매수가 그냥 계약
직전에 그니까 계약 마감되기 정산되기
직전에 갑자기 팍 튀는 것을 보실
수가 있거든요. 그래서 이런 증거들을
바탕으로 어 이런 것은 해징을 하는
정상적인 움직임이 아니라 조작으로
이루어졌을 확률이 굉장히 크다라고
설명을 해 주고 있습니다. 어 그래서
아까 말씀드린 것처럼 이거 그럼 이걸
어떻게 해결해야 되는가 내려와서
보시면 15번 계약에서 그 조절이
크게 약화가 됐다라고 하는데요. 제가
빨간색 쳐 놓은 부분 보시면 그냥
주문량으로 봤을 때도 불 주문량으로
봤을 때도 어이 델타가 0.668
668 정도까지 내려왔다라고 하니까
어 15분 계약에서는 조작이 될
확률이 그니까 주문량이 한 7%
정도밖에 안 늘었다라고 해석하면
된다라고 합니다. 그래서 7% 정도
늘었는데 아까 5분 계약에서는 그 어
주문 자체가 한 50% 정도 상승하고
15분 계약에서 7% 정도 상승하니까
5분 계약을 그냥 높아 봤을 때 5분
계약에서 조작이 일어날 확률이 더
크다라고 의심해 볼 수 있는
상황이다라고 설명을 해 주고
있습니다. 그래서 오늘 내용 굉장히
어렵기도 하고 이제 설명드리기 좀
어려움이 있었는데요. 폴리마켓에
상장이 된 어펜다운 5분 계약이
있습니다.이 5분 계약을 바탕으로 어
프라이스 타겟이 여기 정해져 있는
것을 보실 수가 있고요. 현재 가격을
놓고 사람들이 계속해서 배팅을
실시간으로 하는 겁니다. 그래서이
배팅을 바탕으로 마지막에 정산이
되는데요. 어 옵션과 마찬가지로
만약에 예를 들어서 8시 5분에
계약이 끝난다라고 하면 4분이나
4분이 4분에서 5분 사이 그 사이에
굉장히 많은 거래가 이루어지는 것이
당연하지만 어 지금이 SSR에
올라온이 립 그에 따르면 이런 것들은
5분 계약 그 계약의 특성상 조작될
확률이 굉장히 크고 그런 것들이 실제
데이터로 많이 나와 있다라고 설명을
해 주고 있는 것 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다.
>> 네. 우리 준혁주님이 준비 준비해
주신 자료 쭉 보면서 이제 원문에서
인용해 주신 표를 보니까
>> 미국에서 이제 논문에서 쓰는 그런
폰트 맞아요. 그래서 아 원을 읽고
이거 요약하느라고 애 많이 쓰셨겠다.
그런 생각이 다시 한번 그렇습니다.
어, 제가 잘 모르지만 그냥 쭉 얘기
들어 보면 어, 예측 시장에서의
예측은 사실은 공정해야 되는데
그래야지 승자도, 폐자도 어, 특히
이제 폐자가 승복을 할 수 있게
되는데
>> 예측 시장의 어떤 그 예측하려고 하는
그 이벤트 자체가 단기일수록 조작
가능성이 당연히 있을 수밖에 없어서
>> 그런 부분에 대해서
>> 어, 지적을 좀 한게 아닌가? 그래서
예측 시장을 비즈니스로 모델로 하는
그런 회사들이 앞으로 그 본인의
매출을 넓을 높이고 이익을 많이 얻기
위해서는
>> 어 이제 무엇을 예측할 것인가에
대해서 공정성을 확보하는
>> 것을 꼭 선행해서네 검토를 해야 하는
것 아닌가 하는 생각이 드는데 그런
것들을 이제
>> 학술적으로
밝혀냈다고 하기에는 아직 좀 그렇고
하여튼 지적을 좀 당했다.
>> 네. 네. 정식 전널에 올라간 건
아니기 때문에 뭐 피어 리뷰가 된
거는 아니고요. 그냥 아이디어로서 아
예측 시장은 그냥 저희가 아 예측
시장에서 어떤 확률이 뭐 70%다
이렇게 했을 때 그게 실제 확률로
실제 결과로 이어질게 굉장히 확률이
높다라고 저희가 지금까지 그렇게 알고
있었는데 저도 그렇게 알고
있었거든요. 근데 그런 것들이 5분
계약 좀 단기적인 그런 예측에서는
오히려 맞지 않다. 오히려 그런 거
조작이 될 확률이 높기 때문에 그
방향으로 갔더라고 하더라도 다시 어
원래 가격으로 회기할 확률이 굉장히
높은 어 그런 상황이다 이렇게 보시면
좋을 것 같습니다.
>> 감사합니다. 일부 지금 이제 마치려고
하는데요. 8시를 조금 넘은 시간이
되다 보니까 빨리 마치라고 이제
수고하셨다고 솔트 님 [웃음]
댓글 남겨 주셨어요. 예.
죄송합니다. 오늘 좀 늦었는데요.
일부 빠르게 마치고 더 반가운 분들
2부에 우리 정님, 최부사장님,
오가상 등 뵙도록 하겠습니다. 1부
마치겠습니다. 함께해 주신 채널
여러분 감사드립니다. 입니다.
[음악]
เฮ
>> [음악]
>> ش
안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 여정을
채슬리 투자 전문과 함께 채슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 7월 16일 목요일 2부
순서 시작하도록 하겠습니다.
자, 어제 미국 시장은 전부 올랐는데
반도체만%
좀 조정을 받았고
>> 그렇습니다. 예. 10년 국채 금리는
그래도 빠지고 PPI 더 좋게 나오
>> 예, 그렇습니다. 어, 그래서
계속해서 오늘 어, 저 반도체 하락
이후에 대해서 찾아봤는데요.
>> 네.
기존에는 뭐 창신 메모리 성장이나
이런 뉴스들 또 데이터 센터 규제 뭐
이런 것들은 뭐 가끔씩 나오던
뉴스인데 새로운 뉴스가 뭐 하나
나왔는데요. 로이터발로 뉴스가
나왔는데 코어위브라고 하는 데이터
센터 대하는
>> 업체가 있잖아요.
해
>> 그 업체가 마이크론이나 뭐 샌디스크
이런 데랑 최근에 이제 장기 공급
계약 뭐 SL나 뭐 LTA 뭐 이런
이런 계약을 했는데 어 그 회사가
향후 어 메모리 가격의 하락 리스크를
대비하기 위해서 어 금융 상품을 통한
해지를 고려하고 있다. 어 이런
뉴스가 나왔습니다. 어 그러면서 어
그 뉴스가 어 지금 시장으로부터 시장
참여자들로 하여금 이제 반도체 메모리
가격 고점 친 거 아니야 어 이런
의심을 어 불러일으키면서
어 장중에 상당히 많이 빠졌었고요.
어 그 이후 좀 낙보를 회복했지만
>> 어 그 빠진 채로 어 많이 회복하지
못하고 어 끝나는 상황이 있었고요.
지금 메모리 뭐 계속해서 바틀레기의
공급부족 나오는 상황에서 상당히
이례적인 뉴스가 나오면서 어 사람들을
좀 혼란스럽게 했던 거 같습니다.
>> 거기다가 어 PPI 좀 낮게 나오면서
금리도 하락했고요. 약간 섹터
로테이션, 섹터 브로드 같이
자극하면서 그간 좀 약했던 빅테크
M7 쪽으로 어 자금이 몰리면서
반도체에서 뭐 경계감 내지는 뭐 차익
실현 요런 물량들이
어
그 빅테크 M7 쪽으로 옮겨가지
않았나 어 그런 생각이 듭니다.
>> 네.
자, 비트코인도
스물스물 이제 반등을 좀 못 가는
모습이 나오고 있고 전체적으로이 위험
자산에서 지금 도망가야 될 때냐
아니면
어 여전히 아직까지는 위험 자산에서
수익을 모색할 테냐라고 보면 어
CPI가 좋게 나오기 때문에 지금은
투자자 뭐 저도 마찬가지지만 이제는
어 뭘 사서 서 먹을까?
>> 예. 런 분위기로는 전체적으로 좀
바뀐 거 같고요. 그래서
>> 어 나스닥이라든지 미국 시장은 계속
머리를 조금씩 드는 모습이고 글로벌한
주식 시장도 마찬가지긴 하고요. 아주
강한 시장은 아니지만 그래도 뭐 지금
위험을 해야 되는
>> 그런 부분이는 아니고 JP모관 이런
회사는 어제도 좀 올랐습니다. 그리고
>> 예
>> 블랙락이 이제 큰폭으로 하죠. 6.
%
>> 보하는 모습이고
>> 지금 52주 신고가 보면 전부
파이낸셜
>> 해 가지고 뱅크 오브 아메리카
모건스님 원만 싹스피 무가 어제
말씀드린 대로이 시장이 좀 뭔가
위험한 진짜 회 회색 코뿔소가
우리한테 달려오게 되면 그러면 이런
주식들이 이제 빠져야 되는데 얘네들이
신고가를 내고 있다라는 거는 뭐 크게
문제는 되죠. 애플이 더 신고가가
났어요. 그죠?
>> 근데 애플은 왜 신고가가 나을까?
>> 반도체가이 떨어지니까.
가장 어
짜증을 냈던 분 중에 한 분이 이제
팀이었게
떨어지니까 기다렸다는 뜻이 애플
주가가 올라가는 것이고 그래서
전체적으로는 어 섹터 공략만 좀 자면
된다 생각이
>> 그렇습니다. 6월 어 PPI 나온 거
한번 볼까요?
>> 예. PPI가 어 CPI와 마찬가지로
컨센서스보다 더 낮게 나왔습니다.
헤드라인 보면은 컨센서스가
6.2%였는데 2%였는데
5.5%가 나왔고요.
다들 아시다시피 에너지 가격도
하락됐고 또 식품 가격도 하락했다고
합니다. 이것이 어 PPI를 좀 낮게
만든 요인이고 근원 PPI 같은
경우도 어 컨센서스가 5.2%였는데
4.7%가 나왔습니다. 그러면서 어
밑에 PPI 추의를 보시면은 까만
선이 헤드라인 PPI고
그리고 파란선이
상품 PPI 그리고 어 빨간선이
서비스 PPI인데
다들 어 5월을 기점으로 해서 어
웃하는 모습들이 대략적으로 어 형성이
돼 있고요. 서비스 쪽은 뭐 잘 안
꺾이긴 하는데 상품 쪽이 워낙 많이
꺾이다 보니까 전체 헤드라인 PKI도
5월을 기점으로 픽아웃하는
모습입니다. 그리고
지표 나온 뒤에 어 패드워치에서
어 생각하고 있는 7월 달 FMC
금리의 동결 확률이 89.8%까지
8%까지 올라갔고요.
어제 낮에 ASML 아 실적이
나왔는데 실적 잘 나왔습니다.
요즘 뭐 미국지 뭐 기업 실적 보면은
다 서프라이즈하게 어 나오는데 일단
블랙록도 보시겠지만
서프라이즈하게 실적이 나오면서 크게
올랐고요. ASML 2분기 어 실적을
보시면은 어 매출이 어 10.48
8빌리언 달러가 나왔고 어 컨센서스
10빌년 정도였습니다. Yy로
24.5%가
증가를 했고요.
EOV 쪽에서 어 43.8%가
어 Y로 어 증가한 4.37 빌리언
달러가 나왔고요. 어 매출 총익률도
어 컨센서스 51.98%였는데
98%였는데 54%가 나왔습니다.
영업 이익 같은 경우는 한 4빌리언
정도가 나오면서 yy로 33%가
늘었고요. 어 컨센서 3.5빌리언을
상여를 했습니다. 영업 이익률 같은
경우 37%로 콘센서스 34.7%를
상했고요.
그리고 EPS 같은 경우도 8.8달러
달러 기록하면서 YY로 32%가
증가를 했습니다. 그래서 매출
24.5%
증가. 어 영업 이익 33% 증가
32% 증가 하면서 대체로 컨센도
상의하고 YY 증가율도 좋았습니다.
가이던스도 어이 3분기 기준으로
11.7 7 어 빌리언 달러가
가이던스였는데 빌리언입니다. 어
12.5에서
13.6 1년을 제시하면서 어 좋은
가이더스로 제시를 했고 CEO 발언
쪽 보시면은 AI로 인한 강한 수요
및 고객 케펙스 증액이 가속화되면서
로직 D램 모두 이례적 수준의 장기
가시성이 확보됐다고 얘기를 했고
메모리 [콧방귀] 부분은 특히 공급
부족에 따른 캐퍼 확장으로 인해서 어
매출이 75% 정도 어 증가할 걸로
전망을 했습니다. 그리고 2027년의
필요 주문을 사실상 대부분 확보했고
2028년도
어 다수의 주문 확보로 어 추가
30% 정도 증설 검토 중이라고
밝혔습니다. 그리고 인텔이 최선단
제품 양산의 하이NA를 실제로
사용하기 시작했다고 하면서이 고가
제품인데 고가 제품에 대한 추라도
시작된 걸로 판단이 됩니다. 그래서
그 이익률 쪽 보시면은 영업 이익률이
지난 분기에 36% 지진한 분기에
35% 그리고 이전에 32.8%에서
이번에 37.1%를 어, 1%를 어,
기록을 했고요. 그리고 매출 자체도
그 컨센서스를 상하는 매출을 제시했기
때문에 어, 그 인익률도 어,이 정도
수준보다는 조금 더 계산된 상태로
다음 분기에도 나오지 않을까
싶습니다. 그래서 최종 수요단의 밑에
보시면은 어, 메모리 쪽이 2분기
동안에 6.4
아 빌 유로 달러를 했는데 유로를
했는데 어 작년 하 한해 동안에
8.4 아 유로를 했 8.4유 3 4
6 아 빌리언 유월를 했거든요.
그래서 메모리 쪽이 어이 상태로
가면은 한 12빌리언 유로 정도 어
기록할 걸로 보여지면서 메모리 쪽이
상당히 강한 호조를 나타내고 있고
지역별로 보면은 어 국내가 우리나라가
43% 배출 비중을 차지했고 그리고
타이 30%대
중국 14% 그리고 어 일본 4% 어
미국 어 9% 순입니다. 그래서
메모리 쪽에 다시 한번 수요 자체가
상당히 강하구나 이런 거를 다시 한번
확인할 수 있고요. 어, Q&A 쪽
보시면은 어, 가이던스 상형 있는데이
가이던스 상형 배경은 뭐냐라고 어,
물어봤는데 아 최종 수요가 늘면서
고객이 투자를 늘리고 어 계획을
앞당겨서 올해부터 신규 장비 수요가
발생을 했고 로직, 디뎀, 고객 모두
자기 고객과 장기고 장기 계약을
맺으면서 이례적으로 원점까지 수요가
보이고 있다. 이렇게 대답을 했고요.
로직 시장에서 나타난 흐름은 뭐냐라고
질문했는데 아 기존 선단 공정의 AI
수요로 케파를 크게 늘리는 중이고
2난노 양산도 빠르게 진행되고 있고
고객이 1.4호 양산까지 검토하기
시작했다. 이로 인해서 올해 선단
파운더리 로직 매출은 약 25%
증가할 걸로 어 전망이 된다라고
얘기를 했습니다. 메모리 시장 상황은
어떠냐 해서 DDR하고 HBM 가격이
어 공급 부족을 보여주면서 어 전
고객이 케파 확대를 앞당기는 중이라고
얘기를 했고요. 어 선단 공정일수록
EV 장비가 더 많이 필요해서 어
올해 메모리 매출은 75% 증가할
것으로 전망됐다라고 얘기를 했습니다.
중국 [콧방귀] 매출에 대해서는 총
매출이 한 20% 정도 차지하고
있지만 어 전체 매출 규모가 커져서
실제 금액은 증가하고 있다고 얘기를
했고 늘어난 수요는 대부분 내수에서
나오고 글로벌 흐름과 같은 방향이라고
얘기를 했습니다. 인률이 개선된
이유에 대해서는 마진 오픈 업그레이드
사업 증가가 주요 동력이고여 여기에서
아 시스템 판매량이 늘면서 고정비
부담이 줄었고 EUV 이임머전 장비
호조에 따른 제품 믹스 개선도
더해줬다고 얘기를 했습니다.
26년 이후 장기 수요에 대해서
고객이 어 자기 사업을 멀리까지
내다볼 수 있어서 예년보다 긴 관점에
논의가 진행되고 있고 2027년
주문은 사실상 대부분 확보했고
2028년치도 상당수 확보해서 30%
증서를 검토 중이라고 얘기를
했습니다.
이후에는 어떻게 진행되냐라고 해서
인텔이요 제품을 실제로 쓰기 시작했고
어 모든 고객과 대량 양산 도입 시점
또는 방식을 논의할 예정이다라고
얘기를 하면서 어 메모리 쪽 그리고
파운드리 쪽 상당한
수요가 어 앞으로 28년까지 일어날
걸로 예상이 되면서 좋은 어 코멘트를
남겼고요. 어 주가 퍼포먼스도 뭐
2에서 3% 정도 올랐습니다.
대체로이 기업 실적 발표하고 나면
주가가 빠지고 나는데 어제는 어
이례적으로 좋은 실적에 가능하는
모습이었습니다. 주가 및 EPS는
어 EPS 상향 조정되면서 어 주가는
고점 대비 좀 빠져 있는데 반조체
섹터 영향이라고 보야 될 거
같고요.이
이 수준대로 계속하면 전고점은
회복하지 않을까라고 생각합니다.
PR은 지금 어 39.58배 58배
상에 거래되고 있고 한때 46배까지
갔었는데 어 주가 하락으로 인해서
PR은 좀 빠져 있고 어 EPS는
계속 상형되는 그런 상황입니다.
그리고 블랙독도 실적 발표를
했는데요.
상당히 좋은 실적을 발표를 했습니다.
매출이 7빌리언 달러를 기록했는데
Yi로 31%가 증가했고요. 어
컨센서스 6.82빌리언
달러를 상했습니다.
[콧방귀] AUM이 15 출일년을
넘었습니다. 15.34 출일년을
넘었는데 이게 어 15 출년 돌파한게
사상 최초로라고 하고요. Yyy로
22%가 증가를 했습니다. 아 순
유입이
191.7빌리언인데 7빌년인데
거의 다 ETF에서 순립이 됐습니다.
그 밑에 이제 펀드 플로우면은
ETF에서 2분기 동안 178빌리언
달러가 순유입이 됐고요.
YTD로 볼 때 311년 달러가
순립되면서 어 규모 그 꾸준히 지금
ETF 쪽으로 어 자금이 상단 규모
그 유입되는 걸로 어 파악이 되고
있고요.
영업 이익은 39% 어 증가한
2.9밀리언 달러를 기록했고 영업
이익률 조정 기준으로 해서
45.9%를
%를 기록을 했습니다. 어,
컨센서스는 44.7%고요. 전년
동기는 43.3%를
기록을 했습니다.
어, 조정 EPS 역시 YY로 15%
정도 어, 증가한 13.91달러
기록했고 어, 컨센서스
12.66달러도
달러도 상했습니다. 대체로
어 다텀라인 쪽에서 어 15% 정도가
증가를했고 어 이익률도 45%를
넘으면서 좋은 수익성을 보여줬습니다.
얼마 전까지만 하더라도 그 부회부채나
그 뭐 프라이빗 크레딧 사모 신용이나
어 이런 부분들 때문에 약간 노이즈로
인해서 어 주가가 좀
짓지부진했었는데
그래서 그 관련된 어 코멘트를 좀
모아서 봤는데 오히려 잘되고 있다고
합니다. 신규 자금이 3호 또는
액티브 ETF처럼 볼수이 높은 어
상품에 몰리고 있고요. 최근 인수한
사모시장 관련 기업들의 성과가 어
가시적으로 나타나고 있다고 합니다.
그리고 작년 4분기에 사모신용 관련
이슈 이외 사호 신용 시장은
안정화되고 있고 사모 투자 자산의
신용도에 실질적 변화는 없고 매수요도
매우 견조하다고 얘기를 하면서 어
이쪽에서 그 인수한 기업들의 실적이
어 상당히 잘 견조하게 어 나오고
있는 것으로 어 파악되고 있고 어
최근에 발표한 어 모건 스탠이나 뭐
볼드만스나 JP 모건도 어 3호 쪽에
어느 정도 엑스포즈를 가지고 있는데
아 그쪽에 이슈는 하나도 없는 것으로
나타나고 있고 오히려 어 M&나
최근에 유상증자나 SK 하이닉스
ADR이나 어 스페이스 X나 이런
쪽에 인덱스먼 뱅크 쪽이 상당히
상반기에 호황을 보이면서 어 금융
쪽이
그 실제적으로 아 그런 그런
그 부분들을 어 이번 실적 발표를
통해서 어 숫자로 증명하면서 서
52주 신고가를 기록을 하고 있는 거
같습니다.
그리고 어제 나온 그 7월 펀드벤저
서베인데요.
어 전반적으로 전문님 말씀하셨듯이
주식 시장 미국 주식 시장 보면은
호조를 나타내고 있는 것이 어 미국의
익스포가 조금 늘고 있고요. 그리고
현금 비중이 전월 대비해서도 더
줄었습니다. 전월에 4.1%였는데
지금 3.6%까지 6%까지 어 내려온
상황이기 때문에이 투자 자산에 대한
어 심리 자체는 전반적으로 양호하다
이렇게 어 보시면 될 거 같고요.
그리고 어 미국 주식 포지션 관련해서
어 순지션 기준으로 그러니깐 비중을
확대한 포지션 마이너스 비중 축소한
포지션 이게 이제 순 포지션인데 이게
7월에 24%를 기록했는데 어 24년
이후 어 가장 큰 어 순지션
비중 확 순 포지션 기준으로 어 가장
높은 수준이라고 합니다. 그래서
보시면 많이 높았을 때는 한 30%
이상 어 갔었는데 근래 들어서 어
미국 주식의 순포지션이 상당히 좀
높아지고 있다는 어 그런 부분들이
확인이 되고 있고요.
근데 섹터 로테이션 쪽에서 보시면은
약간 그 로테이션도 어 국가로 보면은
신흥국에서 미국으로 조금 옮겨가는
그런 모습들이 관찰되고 있는데 어
크게 봤을 때 섹터 쪽에서는 어 건강
관리 섹터가 확대가 됐고요. 그리고
국가 쪽에서는
이유 쪽 확대가 됐고 상품 쪽에선 어
채권 쪽 확대가 됐는데 밑에 좀
내려가 보시면 이제 US 쪽에 그
확대가 있었고요. 줄인 쪽은 어
테크하고 어 필수비제 이머징 쪽
그리고 통신 쪽 요쪽이 축소가
됐습니다. 그래서 국가별로 보면은
이머징하고 영국이 좀 축소가 됐고 어
확대가 된 곳은 미국하고
일본 유로전 이쪽이 좀 확대가 되는
그런 모습이고
섹터 쪽에서는 테크나 통신 쪽이 이제
축소가 되고 건강 관리 이런 쪽이
확대가 된 어 그런 상황입니다.
그럼에도 불구하고
지금 어 펀드 매니저들은 이제
센티상으로는
어 쏠림의 정도가 어 가장 심하다고
느껴지는 부분이 어 반도체 어
쪽이고요. 이게 벌써 이제 5월부터
시작해서 어 계속 그 반도체 쪽에
쏠림이 어 크게 나타나고 있다고 어
설문한
그 비율인데 어 5월 보시면은 한
70%대 초반 그리고 6월 제가 그
정확히 계산하는데 이제 6월에
80%였거든요. 근데 지금 7월에
82%까지 어 늘어나고 있습니다.
그래서 어 솔림의 정도가 반도체 촉이
심하게 나타나고 그 다음으로는 뭐 좀
미미한 수준이긴 하지만 M7 쪽에
그나마 솔림이 좀 있다고 생각하는
그런 펀드 매니저들의 응답이 어
많았습니다. 그래서 전반적으로 보면은
아 글로벌 에코티 시장에서
약간의 그 국가별이나 섹터별 어
리밸런싱이 어 나타나고 있는 가운데
반도체 쪽에 어 쏠림은 이어지고
있다. 이렇게 어 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 이상입니다.
음이
>> 펀트 매니저 설베이도 그 제목이 매달
>> 예 그렇습니다. 예. 이번 달에는 어
고통스런 리밸런싱 해 가지고 어
방어주, 배당주 어 이런 쪽에
트레이딩이 어 유효하다 뭐 이런
식으로 좀 나왔습니다. 예.
>> 근데 고통스러운 리벨트. 왜냐면은 그
쏠려 있는 쪽에서 어 그거를 그 다른
쪽으로 옮기려고 하다 보니까 그런
부분들이 조금 힘들 수 있다. 이런
추스플러스 제목이 나왔었습니다.
>> 어
>> 예
>> 항상 그 제목이 재밌더라고요. 보니까
>> 네음
>> 자 펀드 매니저 설베에서
매니저들이 다시이 캐시 포지션이
3.6으로 확 줄면서 주식에 다시
공격적으로 매수를 지금 하고 있는
상태다. 예.
>> 그렇게 볼 수가 있고요. 그죠?
>> 예.
>> 음. 이거는 뭐 좋은 시그널은 아닐
수도 있습니다. 주식 포지션을 잔뜩
들고 가고 있다고 볼 수가 있기
때문에 여기 어 현금 비중 추위이
표에서도 나왔지만이
현금 비중이 가장 많을 때 여기
동그라미를 쫙 쳐 놓으셨는데 22년버
요때 이제 시장이 바닥을 쳤었고요.
20년 에이플 요때도 코로나 때 바닥
쳤을 때 그래서 매니저들도이
좀 쏠려 다닌다라는 걸 보여 주는게이
펀드 매니저들의 캐시 레벨인데
[목을 가다듬음]
어 오히려 주식 비중이 꽉 차 있고
현금 비중이 낮을 때가 오히려 어
조정 가능성이 있는 그런 식으로
해석을 하기 때문에 이번에는 현금
비중을 좀 늘리다가 다시 어 주식을
좀 다시 체험해서 현금 비중이 줄어
있는 상황이긴 한데 이걸 보면 우리가
해석을 해야 될 때 어 저쪽에 위에
현금비중이 6%다. 6%다. 그러면
저 같은 경우에는 아 시장 반등이
들어가며 얘네들이 주식을 허급 지급
하겠구나. 어, 그런 식으로 생각을
하고요.
>> 캐시 레벨이 너무 이렇게 지난번 2월
달처럼 캐시 레벨이 뭐 거의 3%
미만 간도 있었나요?이 이 표를 보면
아 3% 미만은 아니네요.
>> 네.
>> 이게 3% 중반 때였다가
일한 전 같은 건 터지면서
>> 예. 레벨이 다시 또 4% 위로
올라오고 이런 모습이 보였는데 이거
보면서는 어 그렇게 또 추가적으로 사
줄 저 자금은 별로 없나 뭐 이런
생각도 드는데
>> 리밸런싱은 일어나고 있는 거
같습니다.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 네.
그래서 뭘 줄였나 봤더니이
이머직 마켓 줄이고 테크도 줄이고
실수 소비제 쪽도 좀 줄이고
>> 음
>> 반면에 헬스케어 유존
체코 일본 시장 요즘 유럽 나쁘지
않는데 유럽 그리고 미국
>> 예쪽을 열리고 백코티 주식도 좀
늘렸다라고 그렇게 돼 있습니다.
자, 블랙락 실적은 어, 제가 우리
룰브레이커 님이셨나요?
한주 사놓고
주가가 어떻게 움직이는 걸? 예,
꾸준히 이제 지켜봤다 말씀하시는데
30년이 지났을 때 마이크로소프트가
살아남아 있을지는 모르겠지만 30년이
지나도 확실하게 살아남아 있을 회사는
저는
블랙락이다.
음. 그렇게 장기적으로
어 안정적으로 계속 비즈니스를
이어나간다라고
생각되는 회사가 보면 어 주가는
재미는 없죠. 주가는 재미는 없는데이
블랙 같은 회사를 어떻게 활용하셔야
되냐면 어 굉장히 좋은 퀄리티
회사라고 보시면 돼. 우리도 미국
가서 투자 많이 하고 미국의 ETF
많이 매매하시잖아요. 그죠? 이게
글로벌한 트렌드입니다.이 ETF나
금융자산에서
투자 자산에서 ETF가 차지하는
비중이 계속 어 늘어나고 있는데 거기
세계 1등이고
와이
1경이 넘었네 할 때가 얼마 전이었던
거 같은데 지금은 2경 한 2천 넘는
거죠이 정도면.
>> 그렇습니다. 예.
계속 저기 A에 SN 매니지먼트라고
하는 슈타코가
계속 늘어나 계속 늘어날 겁니다.
그거는 아 내년 내후년 3년 뒤에는이
매출이 반토막이 나면 어떡하나 그런
걱정이 하나도 안 드는데
이런 회사를 우리가 퀄리티 회사라고
보시면 되고 어 어떤 이로스
성장주나
세터 모멘텀으로 해서 돈을 많이
벌었을 때 아이 돈을 빼서 집에다가
묻어야 되나 땅에 요즘 어 집 사는
분위기도 뭐 이렇게 되는 걸로
보이던데
집 땅에 묻는 개념이 이런 주식이라고
보면 돼요. 주식 내에서이
좀 변동성을 좀 줄이면서 안정적으로
내가 이번에 번 돈을 지키고 싶은데
>> 예지고 [콧방귀] 싶은데 어디다가
옮겨 놓으면 되지 하면 블랙 같은
주식에 옮겨 놓으시면 돼.
그런 개념으로 지난번에 이제
말씀드렸습니다.
그 투자 관점, 내가 투자하는 기업이
어떤 회사인지 알고 투자해야 되는데
대부분의 분들은 투자하면서 내가 강남
아파트를 사고 있는 건지 아니면 기획
부동산 아파트를 사고 있는지 모르면서
투자할 수다 했잖아요. 그러니까
가격이 빠지면 막 어지둥 뭐 내가 뭐
여기서 손절을 해야 되나요?
강남 아파트를 샀다고 치면 손절할
이유가 없잖아. 그죠?
그런 개념으로 많이 설명을 좀
드립니다.
그다음에
위에가 ASML이고
ASML도 반도체 업에 속해 있지만
거의 블랙 같은 수식이라고 생각이
듭니다.
>> 근데 모르겠어요. 강력한 경쟁자가
나타날지는 [목을 가다듬음]
모르겠는데 아직은 안 보여요. 아직은
>> 아직은 안 보여. 때문에 어
ASML도 보면이 화끈한 맛은 없끈한
맛은 없는데
약간
그 안정적으로네이
회사도 보면
>> 그냥 EPS가 계속 우상량할 회사라는
생각이 들고 그러다 보니까 PR니까
>> 이익의 가시성인한테
2년 3년 뒤에도 이런 실적을 낼 수
있을까?
충분히 낼 수가 있다라는 그런
부분이 어 PR을 놓게 받는 그래서
PR 이런 회사들은 PR 바닥이
얼마고 어느 정도에서 움직이는지 예
PR 밴드 플레이라 하면 좋다라고
생각하는데 어 지금은
EPS가 또 확 올라오면서이 PR이
또 떨어지는 그런 모습이 나오고 있고
>> 한 30배
초반 30배가 깨졌을 때 사면 제일
좋거든요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 그래서 외생적 변수 이런 거에 의해서
확 빠지면
언제든지 사도 되는 주식 중에 하나라
생각하고 있습니다. 지금 이제 지역점
매출 보면 여기서는 하나 좀 특이한게
어 한국 삼성전자 뭐 하이닉스니까
그죠?
>> 예. 43% 그러면
[콧방귀] 어 3점믹스가 43%면
그러면
미국에 마이크론도 있고
[목을 가다듬음] 뭐 회사도 좀
있으니까
>> 예
>> 미국 비중이 그래도 한
15 정도는 돼야 되지 않나음
>> 뭐 그런 생각이 드는데 어 그 의외로
많네요. 예. 9%
>> 9%예.
>> 그지?
>> 예. 이게 뭐 기업별로 브레이크다운을
안 해줘서 잘 모르겠는데.
>> 음.
>> 어.
국내에서
그 1분기 때인가 하이닉스가
엄청나게 그 ASML 노비를
주문했다는 그런 공시가 있었습니다.
그래서
>> 좀 한 업체로 좀 몰린 면이 있지
않나 그런 생각이 들고요.
>> 미국이 미국 하면 이제 마이크론하고
아 인텔 쪽일 텐데 요쪽은 조금
아직은 슬로우하지 않나? 그러니까
이게 한 분봉기라 가지고요. 조금 좀
그렇습니다. 근데 예.
>> 2분기 지역별 출합 규모기 때문에
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 어. 그다음에 중국 매출이 14%
보통 한 20% 언절이었는데 18%
나오고
>> 일본도 뭐 키옥시아도 있고 한대.
>> 예.
>> 4%
>> 밖에 안 나온 거.
>> 근데
>> 주문 주문하고 이제 추라하고 예.
추화가 매출로 인식되는 거하고 약간
시차가 있어 가지고 아 분기별로
보면은 조금 변동성이 있더라고요.
>> 그러겠다고. 예.
>> 자, 다행히 CPI는 좋게 나오고
유가가 떨어진 걸 감안하면 다음
달다음 달 CPI도 툭툭 떨어지지
않을까?
SMP 500의 PER이 지금
20.3이기
기 때문에 금리만 조금만 더 떨어지면
그러면 PR이 또 2배에서 22배
정도까지는 언제든지 오를 수가 있기
때문에
시장이 조금 더 위로 올라갈 룸은
아직까지는 남아 있는
자우스코리아 ETF는 -3%
빠졌는데네 국내 시장으로 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다.네
네.
어제 코스피 지수 6% 올랐고
코스닥이 5.8 오르면서 시장이
그래도 급반등에 성공을 했습니다.
수급적으로 보면 개인 투자자가 2조
4천억가량 이틀 연속 매도에
어 좀 더 힘을 실었고요.이 외국인은
2조 대매수 기관에선 1천억 정도
매수세가 유비됐습니다. 어 선물에서는
외국인이 한 1조 6천억 가량 매도를
했었고요.
투자자 매매 동향으로 가서 보면
외국인 투자자는 SK이닉스 삼성전자
한미반 노체, 주성 엔지니어링,
삼성전기, KB 금융 등을
매수했습니다.
매도에는 PSK, 테스, 대덕전자,
VM, 하나마이크론, 알테오제,
이수페타시스 등을 매도를 했었고요.
기간 매수에는 SK이닉스 대덕전자,
삼성 SDI, SK 스퀘어 등을
매수했습니다. 기간 매도에는 삼성전자
그리고 현대 중업 KB금융,
알테오젠, 현대차 등을 매도를
했었고요.
52주 신고가 종목은 총 12 종목
나왔습니다. 좀 늘어나고는 있는데요.
코스피에서 하나금융지, 다스코,
한성기업, 모나미 등이 신고가의
이름을 올렸고 호스닥그에서는 TSA,
타이거일렉 한국 알콜,
인피니티 헬스케어 등이
신고가였습니다.
네. 음.
자,
외국인은 어제 하이닉스랑 삼성전자를
오랜만에 샀습니다.
기관도 하이닉스를 사고
삼성전자는 기관이 매도를 했 겁니다.
어, 기관이버스를
천업한 거 보니까
버스를 또 개인분들이 또 사시는
거예요.
우리나라 시장도 한화 금융 지주가
52조 신부가를 나타내고 있고 최근에
환율이 좋잖아요. 그죠? 예.
떨어지면서
>> 이번 주식 시장 변동성은 뭐 뭐
우리나라 시장이 큰 난리난 것처럼
보이는데 환율만 딱 쳐다보고 있으면
지난주에 그 급락가는 와중에서도
환율은 떨어지고 있습니다. 그래서
우리나라 시장에 무슨 시스템 리스크가
지금 발생한 거는 전혀 아니다라는
거. 한 금융 지주나이 금융 회사들의
주가가 좋다는 점. 완전히 떨어진다는
점. 그래서 환율이
방향을 잡고 계속 원화 강세로 가면
외국인들 지금 돌아오잖아요.
외국인들이 매수도 하고 있고
그래서 신앙은 나쁘지 않다.
자, 주요 종목들 동량 한번
보겠습니다.
네. 예, 반도체 섹터 살펴보면 대형
반도체주가 반등이 강했습니다.
삼성전자 6% 대니스가
약 9%가량 급등세를 보여줬고요.
아래 소부장 조목들도 반등이 세게
나왔는데 한미 반도체 그저께 실적
발표 잘 나왔음에도 불구하고 시장
하락에 좀 부진했었는데 어제 상한가로
직행을 하는 모습이 나타났고요. 그
외에 코스닥 코스닥 쪽에 있는
소부장도 좋았는데 HPSP공원
이오테크 주성 원니가이패스 등 장비나
소재 부품 기판 다 좋았습니다.
R IT 섹터에서는 삼성 전기가
12% 정도 급등을 보였고요. 나머지
종목들도 대체로 5% 이상의 상승세
보였습니다.
어 플랫폼 섹터 봐 주시면 네이버
카카오 페이 등도 상승세였고요. 어제
니케이 지수 1.5% 5% 반등에
성공했는데 여기도 반도체 쪽이
좋았습니다. 도쿄일렉 이비된 어드반
어 등이 상승세를 보였고요. 배터리
체인도 좋았는데 LG 엔솔 앞으로
3센스테 6% 양육체 쪽도 반등에
성공을 했습니다. 자동차 섹터도
좋았는데요. 현대차 기아 오토에버
등이 상승세를 보여 줬었고요. 소비제
섹터는 어 피용기가 좋았던 거
같습니다. 아래 파마리 서치가 2.8
8 2.8 APL 원택 등이 상승하는
모습이었고
아래 음식료 섹터는 시장 대비 굉장히
부진한 모습이고요. 백화점도 어제장에
좀 반등하는 모습이었는데 신세계 8%
현대 백화점 3% 가량 상승세를
보였습니다.
조선철감및 기타 섹터 봐 주시면 현대
중고업은 1% 정도 상승세로 마감을
했고요. 하나 오션 6%, 하나
엔진이 한 8% 정도 오름세로
마감하면서 조선주의 반등도
나왔었습니다.
철강 화학 섹터 나쁘지 않았고요.
SK 이노베이션도 11%가 그냥
급등세를 보였습니다. 아래 방산주 쪽
봐 주시면 하나요가 6.5넥이
L넥 X1이
디펜스 앤 에어로스페이스 이름을
수정하겠습니다.
L디 디펜스 앤 에어로스페이스가
13% 가량 급등세를 보여줬고요.
현대 로템은 1.4% 상승하면서 좀
차별화되는 흐름이 나왔던 거
같습니다. 바이오 섹터도 좋았는데요.
삼성 바이오, 삼성 에피스 홀딩스
상승했고 아래 코스닥 쪽에 펩트론
최근에 안 좋은 소식 나오면서 18
어 18%가량 어제는 올랐는데 최근에
많이 빠졌거든요. 원스 기준으로
-43%
YTD로도 거의 50% 정도 하락
중에 있는 상황입니다. 어 그리고
아래 금융주 쪽 봐 주시면 KB 금융
상승세 유지했고요. 키움 증권의
반등이 좀 강했습니다. 엔터 쪽은
시장 대비로는 좀 부진한 흐름 나왔던
거 같고요. 변학기 쪽에 반등도
좋았는데 현대 1렉 3% 효성 중공업
LS 1렉 등도 한 7%가
상승했습니다.
네. [목을 가다듬음]
자, 어제 우리 신형이 6% 이상
올랐음에도 불구하고
미국에서 구되는 한국 Ewy ETF는
-3% 야간 선물은 -4.4% 4%
연관 선물은 아무래도이 반도체 하락
메모 이쪽 하락을 아마 좀 해서
움직이는 거 같습니다.
자, 자료 두 개 가져오셨는데이
프리뷰 수주 나오고 탑승하면 늦어요.
어떤 수주 얘기하는 겁니까?
>> 방산 관련 준 이야기데요.
>> 네. DS 강태우 연구원
자료였습니다. 방상 우산 YTD 기준
코스피 대비 약세를 기록 중에
있고요. 원인은 대형수 공백이 좀
지속이 되고 있다. 그리고 두 번째가
캐나다 잠삼 수출 실패에 따른 나토
진입 장벽 강화 우려가 최근에 나오고
있고요. 세 번째는 중동전쟁 장기와에
따른 중동량 계약 지원 우려가 있기
때문이다. 다만 하반기 주요 수가
집중될 것으로 예상이 되고 있고요.
어 주가 상승세가 재개될 것이다.
긍정적인 전망입니다. 하반기 수주
모멘텀에 대한 기대를 좀 해보자라고
하는데 7월에는 K9 차륜형 자주포
미국의 우선협상 대상자가 선정이 될
예정이고요. 두 번째는 스페인 K9
자주포 공동개발 본계약 체결이 예정이
되어 있습니다. 세 번째는 K 전차
페루 봉계약 체결이 현재 기대가 되는
상황이고 특히 스페인 K9 사업은
이미 공동 개발된 M가 체결된 상태고
스페인의 국방비 확대 압박을 가만해
보면 본 계약 체결이 빠르게 진행될
가능성이 높다. 어 폴란드에 대한
러시아 위협이 지속되고 러우 전쟁도
장기화가 되면서 K9이나 천무 등
지상 무기 수요는 나토네에서 더
확대되는 상황으로 보여지고 있고요.
진입 장벽이 높아지기보다는 공동
개발과 협력 확대가 이어질 가능성이
높다. 어 스페인 K9 공동 개발과
어 X파이어 처 유도탄 통합 추신
등이 대표적인 사례라고 볼 수가
있고요. 중동의 파이프라인도 여전히
좀 유효해 보인다라고 하는데 중동
MSM 추가 수출 기대감도 유지가
되고 있고 중동 주요 국가들의 탄도
미사일 요격 미사일 제고가 상단 부분
좀 소신된 것으로 추정이 되기 때문에
한국상 반공망과 요경 미사일에 대한
관심은 지속될 수밖에 없다. 어 중동
정세가 안정화되면 사우디 MNG
사업이나 이크 K선 전차 등 대형
계약 협상도 다시 속도를 낼 것으로
보고 있고요. 하반기는 시장이
기다려온 대용 수주 관련 불확실성이
점차 해소될 가능성이 높다. 이야기를
했습니다. 방산 다섯 개사 EQ 실적
프리뷰를 좀 해 줬는데 상조하고
흐름을 예상한다라고 합니다.
한 에로스페이스는 2분기 영업이
컨센을 좀 소폭해야 할 것으로 보고
있고요. 다만 하반기 폴란드양 K95
미사일 인도가 집중이 되고 호주
이집트 K9 매출도 본격 반영되면서
연간 지상 방사한 이익이 어 증가할
것으로 전망을 했고요. LIG
DNA는 유 어 아랍 에미리트양 천국
매출이 안정적으로 인식이 되면서
2분기 영업이익 1140억 나오면서
컨센을 좀 상해할 것으로 보고
있습니다. 그래서 li DNA를
제외한 뭐 현대 로템 카이 하나
시스템 하나 여론는 어 2분기 실적을
좀 하회할 것으로 보고 있고요.
그래서 대체로 최근에 방산 연구원들
리포트들 보면 LI DNA는 2분기
컨센서스가 좀 사용되고 있는 모습이고
나머지는 좀 하향 조정되는 모습이
나타나고 있는 거 같습니다.
그래서 왼쪽에 표 봐 주시면 이제
글로벌 방산 업체들 그리고 국내 방산
업체의 밸루에이션과 뭐 수익률 이렇게
표가 정리가 되어 있는데요.
오른쪽에 영업 이익 변화율을 좀
주목해서 보면 좋을 거 같은데 하나요
스페이스가 이익이 40.8%
그리고 내년 되면은 28.5% 5%
증가할 것으로 추정이 되고 있고 현대
로템이 올해 18% 내년에
42%인데이
내년 전망치는 어제 방산 세미나를 좀
들어 보니까 대체로 연님들이
새로 물량 정도는 받을거다 정도
전망치랑 이라크 쪽 전망치가 일부 좀
섞여 있는 상황이거든요. 근데 페로는
아마 올해 하반기 나올 것으로 대체로
이야기가 나오는 거 같고 이라크 쪽은
아직까지는 좀 불확실하다라고 합니다.
중 전쟁이 최근에 있었기 때문에
연기된 부분도 확실히 있고요. 중
전쟁이 끝났으니까 이제 정세가 좀
안정되면서이 딜이 나와야 되는데 저
연기된 부분 때문에 당장 뭐 3분기
중에 기대하기는 좀 어렵다라고 보는게
맞는 거 같고요. 그다음 DNA인데
확실히 어 숫자가 좀 좋은 거
같습니다. 26년 예상 47% 증가.
내년이 37% 증가기 때문에 이익
증가분이 꽤나 큰 폭으로 나타날
것으로 보고 있고요. 카이는 올해
69, 내년에 48. 카이도
마찬가지로 좋은 흐름이고 워낙 좀 타
방산 업체 대비 좀 안 좋았기 때문에
좀 회복하는 국면. 그리고 하나
시스템은 127% 그리고 내년에
73% 정도 증가할 곳을 보고 있어서
뭐 이익 증가분만 따로 뚝 떼놓고
보면 하나 시스템이 좀 좋아 보이는
상황입니다.
그리고 아래 어 글로벌 방산 업체들의
상황인데요.
밸루에이션을 좀 비교를 해서 보면
좋을 거 같은데
하나 시스템 뭐 항상 좀 비쌌죠.
올해 예상 실적 기준으로는 70배고
내년은 한 28배. 그리고 LIS
DNA의 경우 올해 38배 내년에
28배 정도까지 떨어질 것으로 현재
추정을 하고 있는 거 같습니다.
그리고 글로벌 방산 업체 중에
대표적인 회사 라인 메탈의 경우 하단
쪽에 있는데요. 올해 예상 실적 기준
26배, 내년에 17배입니다. 그래서
라인 메탈이 밸류에이션이 사실
지난해만 해도 50배 이랬거든요.
>> 네.
>> 근데 주가가 반토막이 나면서
밸루에이션 반토막 났습니다.
>> 어. 어이 컨 실적도 조금 시장
기대치에 못 미치는 것도 있었고요.
그래서 왜 그러냐라고 제가 어제 좀
여쭤 보니까
라인 메탈이나 미국 기업들이나
그 수주를 받아 놓은 건 있는데
캐파여력이 부족해서이 납기를 맞추지
못하고 있다고 합니다. 그래서 어
실적이 생각보다 좀 안 나오는 부분
그리고 가이던스가 조금씩 하향
조정되는 부분이 주가에 반영이 되면서
멀티플이 쭉 내려온 상황이다라고
보는 거 같고요. 근데 또 국내
업체들은 그런 부분에서는 확실히 좀
좋은 부분이 있잖아요. 라인 메탈
대비로 항상 국내 방산업체들의 밸류가
낮게 거래가 됐었는데 눈 떠보니 방산
업체들의 밸류가 더 높아진 상황
볼 수가 있는 거 같습니다.
오른쪽으로 넘어가서 보면 제 LI
DNA만 좀 가져왔거든요. 그 이유가
타 국내 방산 업체들은 2분기 실적
컨센서스가 좀 내려가고 있는 상황이고
>> LI DNA는 2분기 컨센을 비탈할
거다라는 이야기가 좀 나오고 있어서
L [콧방귀] DNA만 좀 가져와
봤는데요.
어
올해 예상 매출이 6조 아 5조
4천억입니다. 오른쪽에 있고요. 영업
이익 기준으로는 4,400억 정도
지금 전망이 되고 있는 상황이고
27년으로 가면 매출 6조
2,700억 전망 영업 이익이
7,억입니다. 그래서 이익 증가분이
내년에 굉장히 크게 나올 것으로
추정이 되고 있고요. 이게 어이
사우디와 그리고 아랍 에미리트로
나가는 천공투의 매출 인식이
본격화되는 어 시즌으로 돌입하면서 L
DNA의 이익이 폭발적으로 늘어날
것으로 현재 추정이 되고 있는
상황입니다. 영업 이익률도 보면
어 올해 예상이
8.2% 정도 추정이 되고 있고요.
내년이 11.5 28년 되면 11.9
입니다. 그래서 L DNA는 사실
이익률이 뭐 그렇게 엄청나게 좋은
회사는 아니죠. 방산업치 치고.
>> 음.
>> 근데 예를 들어 뭐 그런 거죠.
현대로템은 10조 수주를 따내면 2년
반 정도면 다 나가는데 L DNA는
10조 수주 받으면 이게 한 5년
정도 길게 나가다 보니까 수출 절벽이
멀다라는 장점이
>> 확실히 있고요. 그래서 현대로템이나
하나 여유로의 K9나 K2가 수주가
딱 들어오면 주가 반영도 굉장히
빠르고
>> 또 그다음 수주가 안 나오면 한 1년
있도 주가 빠지기 시작하거든요.
그래서 그런 부분이 이제 투자에 좀
차이점이 있다라고 볼 수가 있는데
DNA는 지금 수주 풀이
꽉 차 있는데 거기에 더해서 더
들어올 가능성이 가장 높은 회사 중에
하나다. 왜냐면 최근 일어난 전쟁에서
느낄 수 있다시피 반공에 대한 어
필요성이 굉장히 대투가 되고 있고
요즘은 전면전을 하는게 아니잖아요.
다 주요 시설 타격하고 하다 보니까
>> 이제 방화하는 부분이 굉장히 중요한데
그 부분에서 내 L DNA가 굉장히
지금 앞서 나가고 있다라는 생각이
들고요. 그 최근에 뭐 LI DNA가
라인 메탈과 협업한다
이런 얘기하고 하나로도 비슷한 이야기
많이 나왔잖아. 현지 기업들과 제가
물어보니까 저는 K2전차 같이
폴란드의 공장에
들어가서 현대로템이 뚝딱뚝딱 만드는게
만드는 거냐 아니면은 같이 합작해서
나가는 실적으로 우리가 봐야 되는
거냐 했더니 그 서유롭 쪽이나 이런
쪽으로론 아마 직접은 못 나갈 거라고
하더라고요. 왜냐면 거기에 있는
라인메탈을 비롯해서 여러 굵직굵직한
회사들이 자리 잡고 있기 때문에
우리가 직접 계약을 다해서
수출하기보다 이렇게 합작법인 설립해서
하는 방식으로 나갈 가능성이 높다라고
하고요. 그러면 영업률단에선 그러면
좀 피해를 보는게 아니냐라고 또
물어보니까
>> 그럴 가능성이 좀 낫다라고 하긴
합니다.
>> 음. 그래서 어 [콧방귀] 그런
부분으로 LITAN가 최근에 유럽
국가들과 이렇게 협업하는 이야기가
들리는 걸로 봐서는 일단 협업이
확정이 되면 그리고 숫자가 지키면
이익률에 뭐 타격이 있거나 그러진
않을 것 같다라는 이야기 해
주더라고요. 그런 부분에서는 이번에
라이메탈과의 허업은 긍정적으로 보는게
맞다. 그런 이야기까지 들었습니다.
근데 라이메탈 지금 연초 이후
수익률이 진짜 -37%네.
>> 네, 맞습니다.
>> 우리도 전체적으로는 보면 아, 방산
주가 요즘 왜 이래 힘이 없나? 약간
그런 느낌이 없었긴 한데 지금
LIG만 하더라도 연초 이후 58%
올라 있고 카이나 하나 시스템도
최근에 좀 빠지긴 냈었지만 그래도
연초일료 다 플러스 나오고 있고 하나
에어로스페이스가
-7% 연초
현대 로템도 -1
그러면서 좀 밸루이션이 쌓네요.
보니까 내년 기준으로 14.8배
13.4 배
있고 어 이번에 나토 뭐 캐나다
잠수함도 그랬었고
>> 네에
>> 결국은 유럽 업체들이 많이 가져가는
거 아니냐라고
>> 했지만 그게 맞다면 라인 메탈은
오히려 더 주가가 강했어야 되는
거잖아요.
>> 그렇죠. 네.
>> 계속하는 저는 생각합니다.
그 계속 그 쇼티지 상황인가?
그리고 두 번째는
갑을 관계에서 [음악]
지금 아유 제발 우리 거 좀 사
주세요. 네. 단가 좀 낮춰
드릴테니까 우리 거 좀 사 주세요.
이런 상황이니까 보면 그거는 아니니까
그죠.
>> 네.
>> 그렇다면이 밸루에이션
트레이딩을 해 주면 되는데
보니까 주가가 최근에 반도체로
쏠리면서 이쪽도 [목을 가다듬음]
많이 쉬었잖아요. 그죠? 많이
방산 들고 계신 분들은 되게 힘들었을
건데 그러고 보니까 별주분에서
지난주에 영국 가다 오신 그 AI
전문가 엘리 님이 뭐 얘기하다가
본인은 방산을 많이 들고 있다.
>> 저도 봤는데 예전부터도 그런 말씀
많이 하셨던 거 같아요.
엘리 님이 주식으로
경력은 짧지만 사실 크게 돈을 버신
분이거든요.
그 돈을 아 내가 과연 지킬 수
있을까? 그게 무서워서 지난 2월
달에 저희가서 오셔 가지고 자음도
맡기시고 했는데 너무 이렇게 지르는
나긋나긋하게 얘기하는 거에 비해서
너무 공격적이라서
제가 그러다가 병난다. 안색도 안
좋았거든요.
앉아서 제가 유식으로 돈 버는 것도
중요하지만 이게 성격이 너무
예민하시거나 너무 공격적인 분들은
잘못하면이 강세장에서는 돈을 버는데
우리 회사에서 찾아오신 이유도
지난 11월 그 -4.4% % 시장이
빠질 때 어 반토망이 났다고 반토막이
나는 걸 경험하고 2월 달에 다시
시장이 강했을 때 이러다가 또
조종하면 본인이 진짜 병날 거 같아서
찾아왔다는 정말 잘 찾아왔다
그랬어요. 그죠? 지금은 얼마나이
표정이 좋아요.
>> 음
>> 본인이 그래서 자금 일부 일부만 갖고
해라. 일부만 갖고
그런 얘기를 해.
네.
>> 근데 저도 사실 최근에 반도체 솔림이
좀 풀어지고 이제 사실 코덱스 200
같은 경우에는 급락했지만 동일가중
지수는 그렇게 급락하지는
않았었거든요. 그 얘기는 순남매가
시장이 조금 돌고 있다라는 의미인데
어 조선방산 원전이 원래 기존에
반도체 전에 주도주였었잖아요. 근데
왜 이렇게 멀티 하얀이 지속이
될까라고 어 생각을 했던게 엔진주들
조선 엔진주들 보면은 이익은
28년도까지 계속 성장하는데도
불구하고 오피 마신이 정치돼 있다
보이니까 멀티플이 25배에서 지금
여덟배까지 떨어져 있는 상황이다네
>> 여덟 배까지 떨어져 있는 네배
>> 상황이다 보니까 어 저도 이거에
대해서 굉장히 고민을 좀 많이 했는데
이게 반대로 놓고 생각을 해 보면은
는 기존에 주도주였을 때는 20배에서
25배 정도 멀티플을 받았었잖아요.
근데 과거에 어 그냥 안정적으로
성장이 없이 그냥 꾸준한 실적을 냈을
때 보니까 조선주주들 멀티플이 한
열배 다섯 배에서 열배 정도
봤더라고요. 그 얘기는 영업 이익률이
지속적으로 상향 추정이 되지 않기
때문에 이익은 꾸준히 밀고 올라오긴
하지만 이익이 [목을 가다듬음]
밀고 올라오는 거를 멀티플 하향이 어
주가를 그냥 횡보하게끔 만드는 그런
현상이 좀 발생이 되고이는 상황이
조선방산 쪽에서 계속 좀 지속이 되고
있는 거 아닌가라는 생각이 좀
들었었습니다.
>> 감사합니다.
>> 자 그다음에 리포트가 하나 더
있습니다. 어, 파마 리서치
26년 프리뷰인 거 같은데 제목이
몸집 커진 연어에게 한국 시장은 너무
꽉 껴네
[웃음]
뭐 이런
>> 제목이었는데요.
>> 이분기 실적에 대한 이야기를
했습니다. 그래서 매출 1660억,
영업 이익이 한 660억 정도
전망했습니다. 어, 컨센토스가
650,
7억 뭐 8억요 정도로 알고
있는데요. 그래서 컨센 정도 나올
것으로 보는 거 같고요. 영업률
40%로 추정했습니다. 지난 1분기
제시한 사업부별 QQ 가이던스를
대체로 충족할 것으로 보고 있고요.
내스 의료 기기가 한 600억 정도
추정했고 이분기는 외국인 대상 피부가
채널에 집중하면서 당초 제시했던 QQ
10% 증가를 소폭해야 할 것으로
전망을 하고 있습니다. 수출 의료
기기 쪽은 271억으로 위업향 수출이
순게 진행이 되고 있고요. 유통사
관리 효율라도 이어지면서 안정적인
성자 기대해 보자라는 의견입니다. 어
내스 의약품은 주요 품목 약세로
137억 정도를 예상을 하고 있고요.
수출의 약품은 200 비중 감소
영향에 92억 원 정도 어 나올
것으로 추정을 했습니다. 이게 아마
혼콘줄한 쪽일 것으로 어 알고
있고요. 화장품은 외국인 단체 건강의
효과로 내수 화장품 169억 나올
것으로 보고 있고 독유록 국가 화장품
규제 변경에 대비한 선재적 매출 어
40억 정도가 반영되면서 수출
화장품은 350억 나올 것으로
추정했습니다. 확실히 화장품 쪽은
굉장히 좋은 모습이 이어지는 거
같고요. 그리고 최근에 미국 화장품
제조사 CGUSA 인수를 했다라고
하고요. 아직 뭐 공식이 화되진
않았더라고요. 이제 기사화까지만
되어 있는데 어 미국 사업 확장에
대비한 생산력 확대와 공급망효율화를
위한 결정으로 보여지고요. 기존에는
미국 자회사 DRJ에서 화장품을
제조한 뒤 벌크 형태로 한국에 들여온
다음에 충진 후에 다시 수출하는
구조였다라고 합니다. 이번 CG
USA 공장 확보로 해당 과정이
단축이 되고 증가하는 수에 맞춰서
생산형 확대까지 가능할 것을 현재
보고 있고요. 인수규는 아직까지는 좀
비공개이라고 하고 어 인수전 연간이
회사의 매출은 약 1,500만 달러
수준이라고 합니다. 그래서 규모가
그렇게 큰 회사까지는 아니었던 거
같고요. 올해는 인바운드보다는 수출
성장에 주목을 해 봐야 된다라고
하는데
어 올해는 외국인바운드가 견인한 내수
의료 기기 성장보다는 의료 기기와
화장품의 해외 시장 확대에 따른 수출
성장이 전체 실적을 좀 이끌 것으로
보고 있고요. 내수 의료 기기는 이미
외국인 매출 비중이 높은 데다가 스킨
부스터 제품 경쟁 심화로 전년 대비
성장률 존화가 불가피할 것으로 보고
있습니다. 반만 유료 유료 기기
매출과 고성장하는 화장부수들이이를 좀
상승해 나가면서 사업 목표를 초과
달성할 가능성이 높다라는 의견이고요.
파마리 서치는 연간 가이던스로 매출
Y와Y 25% 성장을 제시를 했었는데
당사 추정 수출 의료 기기나 수출
화장품 성장률 각각 YOY 37 뭐
47%라고 합니다. 20년 연간
매출은 6,900억 정도 영업 이익은
2,850억 전망하면서 타겟 프라이스
48만 원 유지했습니다.
인바운드 쪽에 대한 저희가 기대는
많은데 하마리서치에 대한 이제
리포트들을 좀 읽어 보다 보면
인바운드 쪽은 경쟁이 좀 있다라는 거
같고요. 그리고 좀 작은 시장으로
보는 건지 여기서 성장은 더 나오기
힘들다라는 톤으로 조금 바뀌는
흐름이 나오고 있는 거 같고 그럼
이제 결국 기대야 될 부분은 수출
쪽이라고 볼 수가 있겠는데요. 지금
수출 비중이 지난해 한 38% 정도
올해가 한 40% 정도 추정이 되는
거 같아요. 전사로 많이 올라왔어요.
최출 미정이
>> 뭐 화장품이랑 뭐 피용기 이런 거 다
합쳐봤을 때네
>> 그런 거 같고요.
>> 여기 오른쪽에 지역으로 나녀서 내수
수출 이렇게 나오잖아요. 그래서
계산을 해 보면 그 정도 비중이
나온다라고 볼 수가 있겠고요.음
화장품 쪽이 계속 좀 좋은 거
같아요. 숫자를 보면 왼쪽 표에 좀
나오는데요. 화장품이 올해 예상
매출이 1940억 정도 전망이 되고
있거든요. 그래서 지난해가
1,300억인데 꽤나 높은 성장률이
나올 것으로 추정이 되고 있고이
화장품 쪽은 내수건 수출이건 다 좋은
거 같습니다. 어 그리고 의료 기기
쪽이 이제 미주란으로 볼 수가
있겠는데요.
어 지난해 3,100억 올해가
3,900억으로 사실 여기도 성장이
나쁘지 않습니다. 20% 정도의
성장은 나올 것으로 추정이 되고
있고요. 내수 쪽도 뭐 나쁘지 않은
성장이긴 한데 지난해 워낙 좀
폭발적인 성장을 했다가 어느 정도 좀
둔화되는 모습이 나오다 보니
시장에서는 좀 실망하는 모습이 나오는
거 같다라는 생각이 들고요. 그러면
이제 수출 쪽으로는 수출적으로 우리가
기대해 봐야 되는데 그런 부분에
있어서 파마리서치가 미국에 있는
제조사까지 인수하는 모습이 나타나는
걸로 봐서는 수출적으로 확대하려고
회사도 좀 노력을 많이 하고 있다
생각이 듭니다.
네.
>> 음.
>> 뭐 왕에서 뭐 추가 코멘트 할 거
있습니까?
>> 네. 그 인풍기 실적은 아마 컨센서스
정도에 보합해서 나오지 않을까라고
예상을 하고 있고요. 어 관건은 해외
쪽의 수출을 이제 얼마나 많이 늘려
나갈 수 있느냐가 관건이에요. 그래서
의료 기기 쪽도 그렇고 그리고 화장품
쪽도 그렇고 그게 관건인데 의료 기기
쪽으로의 수출은 지금 유럽 쪽으로
이제 본격적으로 나가고 있어요.
2분기부터 시작이 됐기 때문에 아마
하반기에도 계속 이어지지 않을까라고
어 예상을 하고 있고요. 그리고 지금
가장 기대하는 거는이 화장품
쪽입니다.
>> 화장품 쪽이 생각보다 미국에서 반응이
굉장히 좋은 거 같아요.
>> 그래서이 부분이 만약에 좀 어이
규모가 크게 조금씩 계속 납품이 많이
된다라고 하면은 AP처럼 그런 형태도
한번 기대해 볼 수 있지 않을까라는
그런 기대도 하거든요. 개인적으로는.
그래서 2분기부터 실적은 어
점차적으로 성장이 나오는 구간으로
다시 올라가면서 하반기도 기대해 볼
수 있지 않을까라고 어 예상을 하고
있습니다.
>> 예.
뭐 화장품 이런 얘기 나오면 뷰티
전문가 우리 왕자한테이
파마리 서치의 활용품이이 성공
가능성이 있어요.
지금이 회사 빼고는이 회사는 뭐 잘
되고 있고 다른 회사도 잘 되고
있어요. 수출 나을 때는 물량은 되게
많고 수요도 많고
>> 그래서 뭐 실화에 대한 걱정이 없어도
된다고 생각하고 있고요.
>> 이거 아니면 이거 어퍼는 좋아요.
어이네
>> 어항은 수출 그 되게 좋고요.
그래서이 부분은 뭐 APR까지 갈 수
있는지 잘네
잘 보겠다고네 [웃음]
아무튼 그 방향을 가면 좋겠다고
생각해
>> 네
>> 아 우리 고객분이이 파마리서치 니주라
화정품이 이렇게 뭐 바르는 거 하나
선물해 주셨는데
>> 그거 좀 발라 봐야 돼
>> 효과가 [목을 가다듬음] 좋은지
>> 자 그런데이 지금 추정치 26년하고
27년이 추정치가 쭉 있잖아요.
그죠? 있고 그러면 매출하고 이익하고
어 영업 이익 밑에 나오는데
24년도에1억
그리고 작년에 2,144억
그리고 올해 2,857억
내년에 3,647억
이렇게만 나오면 지금 주가가 70만
원 넘었다가 30만 원 깨졌다가
그죠?
왔다 갔다 하고 있는데 최근에 어
여러 가지 뭐 시장의 노이저들이
있었을 때 이제는 더 이상 빠지지
않더라고.
>> 빠지지 않은데. 자, 이거 실적이
언제 쯤 나와요?
>> 8월 초.
>> 네.
>> 이번에이
되게 중요하죠. 이번 EQ 실적이
중요한게 23년, 24년, 25년
넘어올 때도 보면이 회사가 한 보면
한 5개월에서 6개월 그냥 또 내리
빠지는 경우가 24년 요럴 때도
있었어요. 있었다가
어 그게 4분기 영업 이익이 항상 좀
꺾이면서 아 이제 경쟁이 체열해지고
이번에는 리투도 있었고 그죠.
베르지바에요.
>> 네. 그런 것도 있으면서 경쟁이
치열해지면 영업 이익률이 이제까지 돼
있으니까. 그래서 이번에 발표되는
영업 이익률이 지난 분기에는 39%
정도 나왔었거든요. 분기 영업률이
그죠. 거기서
다시 40%로 회복하는지. 예. 요게
관건인데 왜냐면 Q 성장이 계속되고
있는데 어 OP 마진이 오히려 회복이
되면이 영업 이익이 더 크게 늘어나게
되는 거니까. 그래서 지금 여기 추정
치료는 영업 이익이 664억에 영업
이익률 40% 회복한다고 돼 있어요.
돼 있고 27년 전체적으로도 보니까
어 영업 이익률이 43%까지
올라온다고.
>> 네. 아마 수출 비중이 좀 늘어나면서
>> 마진이 회복할 것으로 보는 거
같습니다.
>> 내수보다는 수출 쪽이 마진이 더
좋은가 보네요.
>> 좋 그니까 좋긴 조금이라도 좋긴 할
것 같긴 한데요. 저번에 실적 발표
때 파마가 얘기했던 거는
>> 내수와 수출의 마진에 큰 차이는
없다라고는 했거든요.
>> 네. 근데 아마 미국이 아까
말씀드렸다시피
그 기존에 지금 미국에 수출 나가는
부분들은
그 되게 복잡한 궁금방을 통해서 왔다
갔다 하면서 수출했다고 했잖아요.
>> 근데 그런 부분이 현지하면은
>> 당연히
1% 포인트라도 맞 이익률이 더 좋지
않을까라고 생각하는게 좀 더
합리적이지 않을까 싶습니다.
천리말을 천리말을 우리가 뛰는 말에
올라타라 이런 얘기 할 때마다 제가
얘기하는게 그거잖아요. 제주도 가서
말 타봤네.
오거장 말 타 봤죠.
>> 저 말도 타 보고
>> 어 낙타도 타 낙타도 타 낙스타도
타봤고 낙타는 도대체 어디서 타는
거야?
>> 20스타
이집트
>> 네네. 오, 중동 갔다 온 적이
있다네요.
>> 중동. 아, 근데 이집트를 갔습니다.
20.
>> 아, 이집트.
>> 그러니까 그근데 타 보면 말 타는 거
어렵잖아.
>> 아, 무섭습니다.
>> 무섭지 않네. 그래서 제가 뛰는 말에
올라타라. 그거는 선수들이나
올라탄다는 거지. 일반인들이 뛰는
말에 올라타다가 잘못하면 부상당한다는
거죠.
>> 뭐 우리가 서커스 단원이냐는 거지.
그래서 뛰는 말에 올라타는게 아니라
천리 말을 가는 말인데 중간에 아예
말이 힘들어서 쉴 때 어 쉴 때
올라타면 되는데 뭘 그렇게 선수도
아니면서 뛰난 말에 올라타서
그것도
소문난 잔치에 끝물에 올라타서 맨날
설거지 당하고 그리고 나서 또 저쪽이
또 잔치 뭐 먹을게 많대 하면서 또
끝물에가 가지고 또 설거지
네. 그러지 말고 그 장기적으로 계속
꾸준히 가는 말인데 주식이라는게 참
다행히 중간중간에 쉬어 준다는 거죠.
쉬어.
그러면 이게 천리마인지 아니면 이제
끝난 말인지 노세한 말인지 그걸
보려면 이제 매출액 성장률하고 이익
성장률을 보면 돼.
근데 그동안은 이제 반도체가 뭐
200% 성장, 300% 성장
나오니까
선수들은 이제 오 저쪽이 300%
달리는 말이 하면서 잽싸게 그죠?
예. 그쪽 와서
>> 가서 달리 선수들은 그게 가능해요.
수들은 그러다가 아 이제 이쪽말이 힘
떨어지고 있네. 좀 쉬야 될 거 같네
하면 다른 쪽 보고 있다가 쉬었다가
이제 뛰는 말. 어 저쪽 이제 뛰는
거 같아.
사실 뛰는 거 보고 이제 타는게
선수들이고
일반인들은 그 달리는 말 올라타는게
절대 쉽지 않습니다.
>> 그러면 그동안에 많이 달렸던 말 다시
쉬고 있을 때 공부해 가지고
>> 음
>> 그런 말 하면 돼요.
>> 음.
>> 자, 우리 시장 어떻게했습니까?
>> 네. 저희 시장 -4.45%로
하락해서 출발했고요. 어, 현재
-4.1%로 1%로 속고 조금 올라와
있습니다.
>> 음. 다시 7천이 깨졌다. 그죠?
>> 예.
>> 코스닥은 어떻게 되고 있을까?
>> -1.94%로
하락해서 출발했고 현재
-1.81%입니다.
>> 어 1점.
>> 자, 내일이 휴일이기 때문에 우리는
약간 연휴 주말 효과.
>> 네.
>> 주말 효과 금요일.
아 주말에 무슨 일이 일어나면
어떡하나 해서 현금화를 만드는 그런
수요가 한 번씩 있는데
>> 이번에는 3일 연휴기 때문에 주말
효과가 더
같이 좀 그게 더 심해질 수가 있는데
강세장에서는 주말 효과가 반대로
작용을 해. 음
>> 뭐 어차피 미국 시장 올라갈 건데
>> 그래서 뭘 현금화를 시켜 현금화 시켜
놨다가 월요일 날 갭상승에 사야 될
수기 때문에
>> 그래서 미국 시장이 어떻게 되는가가
되게 중요해요.
자 미국 시장 어떻게 됩니까?
>> SMP 500 어제 올랐어요?네 네.
오늘도 올를 거 같습니다.
동결 기조로 들어가면서 좀 피테크들
쪽에 투자 심리가 완화될 거 같아서
SPM는 좀 긍정적인 영향을 줄 거
같고
>> 하긴 패드워치에서 그죠? 예.
>> 뭐까지도 좋게 나오면서
>> 음
>> 어 케빈워시가 뭐 이렇게 잘 금리나
막 물가가 잘 잡히면 내려야 될 수도
있다.
>> 네. 그런 얘기도 설척할 정도로
다행히 이제 금리 공포에서는
벗어나면서
그래서 오늘 밤 S표 500.
>> 네.
>> 내일까지 예상을 해야 돼.
>> 이틀 동안. 네.
>> 내일도 긍정적 그 주부터 실적
발표가니까
>> 그때까지는
좋은 흐름 이어갈 수 있을 것 같네.
>> 자, 나스닥은 어떻게 될 거
같습니까? 어제 나스닥은 약간 하락
있었는데.
>> 어, 내일은 상승할때 아, 오늘 밤
>> 네. 오늘 밤에서
>> 오늘 밤 상승이고 내일까지는 어떻게
>> 내일 내일까지도 상승 상승이
>> 아 그래.
>> 자 그다음에 필반 지금 제일 중요한
거는 이제 필반이죠.네 네네.
우리나라 시장 뭐예또 그렇고 반도체에
지금 많이들 이제 좀 몰려 있는데
>> 그렇습니다.음
>> 약간 좀 내무적인 변화들이 조금씩
일어나고 있는 거 같습니다. 수급적인
변화도 그렇고 심리적인 변화도 그렇고
어제 제가 ASM을 보면서
실적적인
측면에서는 그렇게 나쁘지 않은데
약간의 오이지만 나와도 좀 매도세가
좀 집중되는 그리고 이제 다른
쪽으로의 어 로테이션이 일어난 어
상황이라서
조금음
조정이 이어질 가능성이 있을 것
같습니다. 특별한 트리거가 어 나오기
전까지는. 그래서 이틀이지만 소폭
조정 둘 다 조정으로 하겠습니다.
>> 어
>> 일반은 좀 조정이
>> 예
>> 좀 더 이어질 것 같다.
>> 아까 네오클라우드 업체 코위버 얘기
>> 코어위버입니다. 예.
>> 근데 저는 처음 듣는 얘기거든요.
>> 예. 예. 저도 처음 들었습니다.
>> 예. 근데 그게 과연 [콧방귀]
시장에 영향을 줬을까?
>> 음. 그게 영향을 거 같아. 다른
요인들 뭐 CXMT 상장이라든지
어 데이터 센터의 그 지연이라든지
이런 문제들도 뭐 나오긴 했는데 뭐
새로운 것들은 아니거든요. 근데
포이브 관련된 거는 뭐 별거 아닌 거
같지만 뭐뭐 새로운 얘기라서 약간의
뭐 영향은 준 줬는데 그참에 뭐
차익신을 하자 이런 매도 수요가
몰리면서 또 비테크 쪽에서 요즘 좀
간간히 좀 좋은 얘기도 나오면서
쪽으로 좀 수급이 쏠리는 그런
분위기가 아니
>> 그 회사가 뭘 메모리를 뭐 어떻게 숏
쳤다고
>> 아 숏을 친게 아니라요. 그 회사가
샌디스크하고 마이콘 테크날로지하고
메모리 저장 장치 어 장기 공급
계약을 한한 상태에서 어 자기네들이
생각하기에 향후 메모리 가격이 높은
수준으로 했겠죠. 어 떨어질 거
같으니까 어 메모리 가격이 떨어지는
거에 대한 해질을 하기 위해서 아니
그니까 떨어질 때 이익을 보는 그런
금융 상품을 검토하고 있다. 그런
뉴스가 나왔었습니다.
>> 지금은 높은 가격으로 돼 있지
않겠는데 예.
그때 계속 그런 회사는 메모리가
필요한데
>> 예
>> 메모리 가격이 떨어져 주면
>> 오히려 이제 더 좋은 거잖아요. 지금
당장 계약한 거는 좀 높은 가격에
계약했다 하더라도
>> 앞으로 향후 메모리 가격이 떨어져
주면
>> 오히려
>> 오히려 좋은 거 아니에요. 그래서
우리가 조선 업체가 수주하고 나서
>> 그
수주 보통 하고 나면 한 2년 2년
반에 빨리 가면 한 1년 반 예 그때
나중에 가서 환율이 확 떨어지면 달러
베이스로 계약을 하다 보니까
>> 음
>> 그래서 저기 조선 수제 해 놓고 그
환에 대해서 어 해치를 하는 거는
그거는 일반적인데
>> 예
>> 이런 포이브 같은 회사가 메모리를
계약을 했고 근데 향후 떨어지면
떨어지는 거에 대해서 이미 계약한
거를 가지고 메모리 가격이 전부 다
내 다음 분기 다 분기 내운년 초까지
올라간다고 하는데 걔네들이 떨어지는
거에 배팅을 해서 지금 메모리 가격
계약한 거에 대해서 떨어지게 되면
이익을내는 걸 한다.
>> 예.
그러니까 어 그렇게 써 있더라고요.
그니까이 이게 뭐 계약이 체결되고
이런 건 아니고 검토 단계인데 지금은
높은 가격으로 장기 공급 계약을
맺었을 텐데 그건 그거고 아 그
포지션에 대해서 어 떨어지면은
이익을 보게 되는 포지션이 있고
그다음에 이제 떨어진 가격으로 그
계약을 할 때는 그건 또 그거대로 어
지금보다는 상대적으로 이익을 보는 어
그런 이중 수혜를 보게 될 수 있다.
뭐 그렇게 있는데
>> 잘 모
>> 뭔 말인지 알겠는데 그런 이슈가
>> 그 수많은 자금들이 어 주식 세장에
모여서
>> 예
>> 적정 가격을 찾아가는데
>> 그렇게
스마트해 보이지 않는 그런
>> 예
>> 걔네들의 그런게
뭐 시장에 그렇게 영향을 주나 그런
생각도 사실
>> 예 맞습니다. 저도 좀 그렇습니다.네
[웃음]
>> [콧방귀]
>> 재불 사장님이 그 정도 얘기에 흔들릴
분은 아니시잖아요.
>> 예. 그런데 일단은 어 그거는 뭐
노이즈라고 생각을 하는데
>> 일단은 자금의 어떤 큰 이동이나 또이
메모리 쪽 반도체 쪽의 어떤 아
지금의 조정을 어 뒤집을 만한 어떤
큰 모멘텀이나 뭐 요런 것들을 조금
기다려 보자는 어 생각입니다.
아까 ASM에 대해 그 실적 발표를
보면
>> 여전히 수요가 단탄하다.
>> 예.
>> 저는 그런 생각이 들어 가지고
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 오히려 이런 ASML이나 이런 회사가
발표하는 그런 내용이 훨씬 더
신린성이 있는 거죠.
>> 예. 그렇죠. 근데 뭐 이틀 동안의
그 상승 하락요 정도를 그 맞추는
것이기 때문에 일단은 이틀 정도는
조금 더 그 예 좀 더 심리적으로
>> 어 좀 더 관망 또는 약간의 이제
경계 모드 그리고 [콧방귀] CXMT
상장에 대한 뉴스플로우 이런 것들을
좀 지켜보자는 그런 관망심리나 경계
심리가 좀 강하다는 강할 것 같다는
차원에서 어 말씀을 드렸습니다.
입니다. CXMT는
정확하게 상장 일자가
>> 아직도 공개하지 않는데요. 그런데
우리는 뭐 안 내용 따라서 하면
27일 전장입니다.
>> 7월 27일?
>> 네. 월요일.
>> 월요일이에요.
>> 네. 하세요.
>> 아니면 22일 저녁이 그때는 회식이
있어요.
>> 아
>> 장하기 전에 그냥 파티 이런 거
있잖아요.
>> 아 상장하기 전에 뭐 파티네 맞아요.
22대 6일 파티 잡고 27일 성장
>> 자 코스피 코스닥 코스닥 또 음봉
나왔죠?
>> 아 양봉
>> 아 양봉이에요?
>> 네. 어,
어제 양봉이라고 강하게 얘기했다.
>> 감사합니다. 네. 네.
>> 우리 옛날부터 한 25년 전부터
시스템 트레이딩 이런 거 다 개발해
봤잖아요.
>> 네.
>> 어,
오늘은 양봉.
>> 네. 오늘 양봉은 나왔습니다.
>> 지금 분위기로는 시초가 대비해서 지금
좀 빠져 있지 않나요?
>> 네. 시가 대비해서 한 1% 정도 더
빠졌.4로
시작을 했는데
코스피는 어떻게 될 거 같아요?
도 5일선을 이탈해서 내려
와 버렸는데
어제 아마 이제 시청 다시 반등하
해서 따라붙었던 사람들 또 매도
물량을 소화하고 있는 상황인 거
같거든요. 음.
>> 이걸 또 받쳐 줄 수급은 그렇게 많지
않고 하다 보니 시장이 밀려 버렸는데
내일이 또 쉬는 날이기도 하고.
하지만
양봉해 보겠습니다.
>> 어, 양봉
혹시
>> 물러날 곳이 없다. 양보.
>> 어.
일봉 모습으로만 보면 고과장이 얘기한
대로 어제 5일선을 뚫어놨는데
최근에도 보면 떨어지는 와중에 어
급락 나오고 이틀째에
그 5일선 뚫었나 싶은데 그다음날 어
시초가가 중요한데 시초가 마이너스로
시작하게 해서 5일선이 깨지면 다시
손절 이게 트레이딩하는 선수들의
원칙이 있어요. 그죠? 짧게 짧게
매매하는 선수들이 어 5일선 회복하면
들어가고 깨지면 다시 손절하고 나오고
그런 모습이기 때문에 오늘 시초가
낮게 시작해서 아마 어 어제 들어갔던
손수들은 또 기계적으로 아마 손절을
할 거예요. 그런데
그저께 시장이 어 패닉셀링이 나오고
바닥에서 어제도 보면 곧버스
매수도 들어가 있고
그렇기 때문에 여기서 조금 더 밀리면
그저께 못 사서 좀 아쉬웠던 사람들이
어
살 걸 했었던 사람들이 또 매수가 좀
들어온다고
그리고 7천 이하에서 해서 사는 거는
뭐 크게 위험하지 않으니까
반도체만 좀 삼성전자 하이닉스만
수급이 약간 좀 보이고 있어 가지고
그 부분이
쉽게 빠르게 반등 들어가지는 않겠지만
다른
섹터는 아우 이제 삼성전자 하이닉스
이제 조정받으니까 숨통 좀 터이네
하면서 매수가
좀 더 공격적으로 들어올 것 같아.
그게 다 맞물리면서 야 근데 3전
하이닉스
두 개가 합쳐서 50% 아직 넘잖아.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 그러니까 좀 헷갈리는 거죠.
>> 그래도 양보
근데 사이드 카 걸리면 웬만하면
서킷까지 한번 갔다 오더 요즘은
>> 여기까지
>> 서킷이 8%인가?네
>> 맞습니다. 네.
나는 오늘 서킷 안 간다.
오늘은 서킷까지 안 간다.
>> 음.
>> 왜? 그저께 한번이
세게 나왔었기 때문에 아까 말씀드린
대로 아 어 빠지면 사야 되나? 그
대기 매수도 좀 있다고 봐야기
때문에.
서킷까지는 안 가고 여기서 매물
소화를 또 10시 반 정도까지 하고
외국인이 최근에 매수들로 보이잖아요.
>> 예.이 [목을 가다듬음] 외국인
입장에서는 나는 오늘도 뭐 매도
나오더라도 별로 많이 매도 안
나온다고 봐요. 반도체 쪽은 4
5천억 정도
>> 예 반도체 쪽이 매도가 좀 있겠지만
다른 쪽은 오히려 매수가 좀 들어올
가능성도 있기 때문에요
정도 언저리에서 약간 십자 모양이나
살짝도
날 수도 있겠다. 아까 우리 주창
프로가 얘기했듯이 미국 시장이 오늘
내일 딱 괜찮을 거니까.
자, 시장이 워낙 이제 좀 변동성도
심하고 해서 시간이 좀 가더라도 이거
저거 저희가 좀 따져봤습니다.
변동성장에서
대응을 잘하시고 아까 말씀드린 대로
우리가 주식을 하시면서 제일 영리하게
주식하는 방법은 어 저쪽에 잔치
열렸네 했을 때 내가 10명 중에
세 번째 정도 가면 제일 좋다했잖아.
>> 세 번째 정도. 왜냐면 첫 번째로 딱
가보잖아. 아이 뭐야 이거? 여기 왜
맛이 없어? 이럴 수가 있어요.
>> 음.
>> 근데 앞에서 딱 간 사람들이 야 여기
와 엄청 맛있네. 예. 그랬을 때
잽싸에 가야 돼. 세 번째로. 세
번째네 번째로 잽사이 가서 먹고.
근데 끝까지 먹고 나오면 안 된다죠.
>> 음.
>> 예.
끝까지 세 번째네 번째로 가서
먹었더라도 끝까지 먹으면
설거지나하고나
[웃음]
끝까지 먹어 나오면 마지막 열 번째
하면 잔치 이제 끝날 때까지 먹으면
>> 어 어디가 설거지하고 가야지 그게
제일 억울한 사람은 여덟 번째 아홉
번째
>> 음네
>> 먹지도 못하고 설거지하고 오는 사람이
>> 좀 약은 사람은
>> 어 일곱 번 여덟 번째에 나오면서
야, 여기 맛있어. 여기 와서 어,
좀 더 뭐 여기 되게 맛있어. 먹어
봐 본인은 나오는 거죠. 본인은
나오면서 주잖아 여기 맛있어 하고
솔거지 시키는 거죠. [웃음]
그러면서 나와 가지고 또 다른 잔치
어디 열리나 이래 눈치 보다가 어,
저기 잔치 시작한 거 같네.
>> 예. 그러면서 또 거기 가서
>> 예. 그게 말처럼 쉽지는 않습니다.
쉽지는 않은데 항상 그런 말 그런
생각을 하시면서 투자하시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 예. 체슬링 모닝 브리프
오늘 7월 16일 순서는 여기까지
하겠습니다. 체슬리와 함께 즐기없고
행복한 투자 하시길 바라겠습니다.
고맙습니다. 감사합니다.